il
[Musique]
bon matin mesdames et messieurs donc ici
est de montréal au centre de
l'information
nous allons vous présenter toute la
matinée
ce début de campagne électorale quarante
jours de campagne une campagne beaucoup
plus courte cette année on le beaucoup
un souligné nous connaissions depuis 4 1
la date de l'élection le scrutin je vous
le rappelle est le 21 octobre
maintenant monsieur tron doit décider
aujourd'hui de déclencher à 10 heures on
aura des images il sera chez la
gouverneure générale où il demandera la
dissolution de la chambre des communes
commencera donc à ce moment là la
campagne électorale les quatre chefs
hongrois donc un traitement et une
visibilité égal si on a autant parlé
depuis quelques jours delà du
déclenchement ou non c'est exactement
pour ça parce qu'une fois que la
campagne ait déclenché bien sûr monsieur
trudeau reste premier ministre mais il
est surtout candidat donc chef libéral
mais ce chiffre devient chef que les
chefs conservateur et ils auront dans
les médias canadiens chez nous ailleurs
à peu près le même traitement un
traitement en tout cas équitable
quarante jours pour vous faire une idée
c'est important on l'a beaucoup souligné
depuis plusieurs mois les campagnes
électorales change la donne
aujourd'hui c'est important c'est un
exercice démocratique important daniel
thibault attend d'ailleurs le premier
ministre qui va faire son entrée dans
quelques minutes une heure une heure et
quart daniel bonjour à vous voilà alors
racontez nous un peu comment ça va se
passer
c'est ce rituel est pas nouveau un soir
il yad'autres premier ministre monsieur
trudeau qu'ils ont traversé ce que l'on
voit derrière c'est l'entrée principale
de rideau à la porte principale c'est
long mais je trouve arrivée devrait
arriver flanqué d'une trentaine de
quarantaine de militants de partisans se
trouve entrer à l'intérieur pour
rencontrer la gouverneure générale julie
payette et là la façon dont ça se
déroule ça c'est clair et ça fait partie
de la tradition il ya trois éléments se
trouvent à soumettre sa demande et pour
la distribution de la chambre des
communes daniel on le voit déjà il un
israël plutôt parce qu'on le voit des
images en direct il va reconduire à
l'école les enfants
est ce qu'une erreur bad romance avec sa
femme un café en tout cas ce sont des
images de synthèse à la marche dans le
parc et ayez pas très loin vous savez
que depuis que ce trudeau a décidé de ne
pas loger au 24 sussex de leur côté de
la vue la résidence officielle du
premier se trouve sur les terrains de
doral juste un peu plus loin ainsi à la
voudra t il accélérer le pas peut-être
ce que l'on nous dit en tout cas dans
son entourage tant du côté du bureau du
ministre que du côté de rideau à six
coeurs il devrait être ici d environ 10
heures ce matin à la même période
baroque signé tran programmation une
première pour dissoudre le parlement une
seconde pourrait mettre les brefs
électoraux ont déclenché cette campagne
là une troisième pour prévoir le retour
de la chambre des communes après le 21
octobre
c'est une tentative évidemment mais ça
fait partie de l'exercice
constitutionnel et quand tout ça est
signée ça devrait prendre nous dit-on
une trentaine de minutes quand c'est
terminé
mais chut renault va ressortir par la
porte principale et là elle va venir un
podium qui est installée juste à ma
droite ici où il répondra aux questions
des journalistes vous disiez tout à
l'heure
il commence à ce moment là c'est à ce
moment là qu'on va faire référence
on va dire on va dire de lui qu'il est
le chef libéral même s'il demeure
premier ministre on va parler lui comme
le chef libéral et quand c'est terminé
ici bas ils sautent ils sautent dans les
voitures ils s'en vont à l'aéroport pour
commencer la campagne électorale
monsieur trudeau on le rappelle qui
souhaite un deuxième mandat dans
l'histoire moderne du canada une fois
qu'un premier ministre est un parti a
été élu pour un premier mandat
règle générale ça a été comme ça chaque
fois les canadiens redonne un second
mandat parfois minoritaire on n'a qu'à
penser au père de monsieur trudeau qui
était rentré grandement 68 qui a eu un
gouvernement minoritaire en 72 mais donc
shaw changé et le temps s'accélère et ce
qui était vrai dans le passé n'est pas
garant automatiquement pour lui de
second mandat donc le défi pour monsieur
trudeau reste énorme il ne peut pas
perdre beaucoup de députés s'il veut
garder un pouvoir ici lui fait regarder
dans un scénario idéal la majorité non
voilà c'est intéressant parce que les
cette campagne là on connaît la date
depuis déjà un petit bout de temps on
s'est fait depuis quatre ans que
l'élection va avoir lieu le 21 octobre
il y avait une fenêtre pour monsieur
trudeau pour déclencher la campagne est
une décision stratégique de la
déclencher aujourd'hui il aurait pu le
faire le dès le 1er septembre il avait
jusqu'au 15 pour le faire les stratèges
libéraux semblent être en mesure ou
semble penser qu'ils peuvent capitaliser
sur la glissade du vote nous démocrates
entre autres au québec pour compenser
entre autres certaines des pertes qui
sont anticipés dans les présents dans
les provinces atlantiques et puis là
quand vous parlez aux libéraux et aux
conservatoires de part et d'autre on
mise beaucoup sur l'ontario sur les
gains peuvent être faits là bas derrière
monsieur t et ensuite il ya les
batailles à 3,4 là sur la côte ouest
hier que trudeau je présume comment
avoir l'occasion d'en parler abondamment
plus tard mais monsieur trudeau quand
l'élection est déclenchée lui qui est
immédiatement pour aller sur la côte
ouest pour aller dans la région
iliad il ya des batailles et intéressant
qui se dessine là bas et ce que l'on me
disait aussi c'est que dès qu'il a
terminée vancouver il revient au québec
assez rapidement parce que on veut on
veut montrer que le québec est important
on mise beaucoup sur les gays affaires
au québec ça tout le monde dans
l'organisation libérale nous en parle la
coulisse et en privé depuis plusieurs
mois
on espère aller chercher une quinzaine
de circonscriptions
sinon plus au québec parce que ça c'est
ce qui pourrait permettre au
gouvernement
un monsieur trudeau justement d'aller
chercher cette seule second mandat dont
vous parliez à quelques minutes très
bien on va montrer les données au point
de départ de cette course dissolution
dans quelques secondes donc le nombre de
députés que chaque parti détient
actuellement pas tout à fait le même nom
que lors de la soirée électorale en 2015
parce qu'il ya eu comme vous savez des
partielles des démissions et cetera
les libéraux partent ce matin avec 177
députés les conservateurs 95
le npd 39 10 pour le bloc québécois
il ya eu huit indépendants de verres et
voilà monsieur bernier qui représente le
son parti populaire canadien avec moi
tout au long de cette matinée pour cette
émission spéciale
alec castonguay josée legault est à
shaqiri jean bonsoir bonsoir ou bonjour
pardon bonjour 3 l'habitude l'habitude
bonjour à vous trois tours de table
rapide on vient de voir les forces en
présence
je disais l'histoire est du côté d'un
second demande de monsieur trudeau mais
l'histoire n'est plus la même non plus
le temps et échangeant pour le vu un peu
partout sur la planète
le temps est changeant c'est vrai qu'au
canada depuis les années 30 on a
toujours un deuxième mandat d'un
gouvernement dont l'histoire
effectivement joue en faveur de monsieur
trudeau mais vous savez l'accélération
du rythme de nouvelles les réseaux
sociaux les gens c'est un peu plus
rapidement du changement on le veut un
peu partout sur la planète donc il ya
cette force là aussi qui jouent contre
justin trudeau cette force d'avoir
petite nouveauté quelque chose de
différent
donc on dit souvent qu'un campagne
électorale c'est d'abord un référendum
sur le gouvernement sortant faut d'abord
que les gens se demandent si oui ou non
ils veulent régler le gouvernement en
place puisse y ait ensuite ils se disent
oui bon on regarde les alternatives
place moment l'ont choisi pour l'instant
je pense qu'on les gens n'ont pas
vraiment la tête aux élections pour être
bien honnête on est réuni ici on a du
plaisir au même sommet les candidats me
disais sur le terrain et encore 50% des
portes auxquelles on frappe qui ont
aucune idée qu une campagne électorale
sans vient donc on n'est pas rendus à se
poser la question si on aime encore
justin trudeau pour quatre ans à venir
tranquillement au fil de la campagne
peuvent absolument jour j c'est comme ça
à chaque fois d'autant plus qu'on le
répète elle est plus courte
oui elle est plus courte alors ça va
bouger quand même assez rapidement
moi j'ai confiance que les gens vont
vraiment s'intéresser parce qu'il va y
avoir quand même des enjeux on en parle
beaucoup il n'y a pas de grand projet il
n'y a pas tout le monde est à la
recherche d'un projet de société le bon
mais aussi des visions très différentes
je pense qu'ils vont être présentés par
justin trudeau qu'une vision si on se
fie aux un peu au plan de campagne alors
au slogan plus plus qu'une vision plus
collective plus tourné vers l'avenir je
choisi d'avancer bon non j'ai choisi
notre port culé qui recule les
conservateurs ont bien entendu et le
message lui de 2 1 du refus des
conservateurs beaucoup plus
individualiste à il nous parle nous
plonge pour mettre l'argent dans votre
poche vous pour vous ça va aller mieux
pour pour le collectif c'est épais et
aussi on voit les autres les autres
messages aussi qu'ils vont se décliner
on a le temps d'en parler pour les
autres partis mais je pense qu'il ya un
chouette vision km et on veut l'entendre
dès ce matin parce qu'il y aura mesdames
et messieurs les discours des points de
presse de tous les chefs qu'on va vous
présenter ce matin en cascade comme ça +
trudeau et le premier allait donc devant
les journalistes ensuite on va comme ça
entendre les six chefs mais monsieur
bernier qui est à toronto qui va donner
un point de presse de tasha kheiriddin
il ya quand même deux effectivement
comme dit josé à deux visions au moins
deux visions qui s'affrontent deux
visions mais je ne suis pas d'accord que
ces rencontres le collectif que monsieur
cheikh se présente je pense que c'est
plus contre les élites ça va venir
rejoindre le populisme ok là les cafés
référence je pense que ça va être en
question pendant la campagne et ça va
bénéficier non seulement potentiellement
les conservateurs n'ont su les verts
parce que je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont frustrés avec les partis
traditionnels un peu un emprunt à la le
groupe qu'on en avait au québec
est-ce qu'ils vont choisir une autre
option à ce que ça va être madame mais
par exemple
et si la question environnementale aussi
pour moi c'est vraiment quelle va être
la question aux yeux si c'est
l'environnement
mais ce truc dont je joue beaucoup là
dessus mais c'est un couteau à deux
tranchants
parce que pour lui en
colombie-britannique le fait qu'il a
approuvé trois dimensions
ça marche comme ça va contre lui et dans
d'autres parties
au québec aussi les gens sont très
conscients de l'environnement alors
encore est ce que moi je regarde les
verts le parti plus intéressante cette
élection à ce qu'ont récolté 7,7 ciment
sa mère que monsieur trudeau a fait et
l'autre côté delà de cette phase là
quand on regarde les verts c'est se
demander est ce que le npd va survivre
oui un peu gros comme question mais ça
se passe swiss post qui seront en
chicane présentement et on voit les
directions encore nouveau brunswick les
gens qui sont partis je les paie des
ovaires les candidats c'est ça et je
pense que c'est vraiment la chicane sur
le côté progresser ses intérêts sens
très bien sur le terrain bien sûr on
sera avec les chefs tout au long de la
campagne électorale parce que gas les
enjeux qu on va décortiquer ici du
canada il ya l'épreuve des faits aussi
parce qu'ils disent la vérité est ce
qu'il manque
est-ce qu'il joue avec les chiffres et
chefs dont tout au long de la campagne
mais aussi et ça c'est très important de
ne pas oublier ça si on veut savoir les
canadiens veulent savoir qu'est ce
qu'ils ont dans le ventre et prendre la
mesure des capacités intellectuelles
stratégique émotif même des chefs et
tout au long de la campagne des
journalistes que vous voyez vont les
suivre sur le terrain et nous tenons à
être là présent oui ça coûte une fortune
petite parenthèse c'est important mais
c'est important que les journalistes et
qu'on puisse poser des questions en
français partout au pays
alors fait l'évinça poisy vous serez
avec justin trudeau je commence avec
vous il s'envole on l'a dit vers la
colombie britannique
dès le début de cette campagne oui
vancouver kinzo et il va s'envoler en
début d'après midi donc après la
gouverneur générale après son point de
presse va s'en venir ici à l'aéroport
pour s'envoler vers vancouver là vous
l'entendez autour de moi je suis sur le
tarmac où l'avion de justin trudeau avec
les couleurs libérales le mot trudeau
2019 bien affiché bien en vue donc on
est prêt ici à s'envoler un peu plus
tard cet après midi on va commencer la
campagne à vancouver chez les libéraux
en colombie britannique c'est une des
provinces là où
il ya beaucoup de sièges qui vont être
en jeu où les verts ont un potentiel de
gain aussi donc justin trudeau veut
marquer le coup commencé là pour montrer
que les libéraux sont encore présents ou
encore un message environnemental et la
stratégie libérale patrice va être de
montrer que les libéraux sont là pour
offrir quelque chose de nouveau et ce
dès le début de la campagne
donc on va voir justin trudeau dans les
premiers jours essayez d'aller dans
chaque province canadienne
on devrait le voir vendredi au québec
notamment et ensuite de faire plusieurs
annonces dans les premiers jours dans
les premières semaines aussi pour
montrer qu'on n'est pas là uniquement
pour défendre le bilan parce que ça peut
être compliqué les gouvernements ne sont
pas réélus en défendant uniquement un
bilan ils sont réélus en amenant de
nouvelles promesses et ça chez les
libéraux on en est bien conscient donc
on veut vraiment aller de l'avant avec
de nouvelles mesures je sois en
environnement que ce soit en fiscalité
pour le contrôle des armes à feu aussi
donc on devrait avoir plusieurs annonces
dans les premières semaines du côté du
parti libéral vraiment pour montrer
qu'ils sont là pour offrir quelque chose
de nouveau donc vancouver ce soir le
déroulement en fait il va y avoir un
événement partisan et ensuite on va
vraiment voir justin trudeau sur le
terrain dans plusieurs circonscriptions
sillonner le canada
les libéraux nous disent on prend aucune
province pour acquise et aussi on ne va
pas en négliger certaines certains
pourraient dire par exemple l'alberta
les conservateurs devraient être
capables de tapis seat bleue cette
province le libéro 2 on est capable de
garder certains sièges à edmonton et à
calgary
donc on va aller se battre pour ces
circonscriptions la même dans des
régions où en ce moment les sondages ne
sont pas favorables très bien et on va
revoir les données de la dissolution
en fait c'est pas si compliqué les
libéraux ne peuvent pas se permettre de
perdre plus que 12 13 circonscriptions
pour ne pas baisser sous le seuil de la
majorité et pourrait garder le pouvoir
qu'ils en perdent un peu plus voyez les
chiffres 177 alors que les conservateurs
doivent aller chercher soixante dix
circonscriptions alors c'est ce jeu là
les libéraux veulent garder leurs acquis
et les conservateurs doivent faire des
gains importants
tour de table là dessus au oui
officiellement on dit qu'on va aller
partout et dans les faits on va miser
sur des endroits bien particulier au
début on voit un peu partout mais plus
la campagne va gagner en intensité plus
on va cibler des circonscriptions et des
sondages qui sont tous les jours ils
savaient exactement où sont les luttes
donc regarder les tinner des chefs
particulièrement dans une campagne assez
court d'une quarantaine de jeux aux 4 78
jours comme en 2015 peut sillonner le
pays a pas beaucoup de conséquences
quand on a 40 seulement une campagne qui
vont y débat avec des débats en plus qui
ralentissent les caravanes mais quand
une campagne rondement il fait quoi deux
circonscriptions par jour 3 dans les
milieux urbains
faites le calcul on ne peut pas visiter
les 338 circonscription donc on va se
concentrer dans des endroits fort
potentiel pour chacun des participants
pied tous les analystes disent depuis
des années les gouvernements se
choisissent en ontario tâche à la
couleur du gouvernement se choisit en
ontario et la majorité et ceux des
terminaux québec ou non minorité c'est
encore vrai cette année là oui le québec
cet intérêt qui est vraiment et le
québec et la colombie-britannique suel
d'entre nous aujourd'hui
oui mais le québec c'est très important
parce que on voit justement la
dégringolade de l'aide pda qui savent a
profité ce que le bloc va ressurgir va
reprendre ces votes est ce que les verts
vont prendre
est ce que le parti de maxime bernier va
gruger des votes aux conservateurs ont
ces passages où ça se joue ici
non ok l'atlantique les conservateurs
vont vont prendre des sièges
probablement on se sait s'il ne
peut-être jacobins en atlantique les
libéraux ont tous les genres ses
peintures et en rouge partout c'est
triste d'enchères de 2,3 je pense que ça
va être un ouragan conservateur mais
peut-être petite vague conservatrice qui
va qui va les récoltes et certains mais
à part de ça le reste du pays
et comme on a dit c'est ça on ne peut
rien prédire à ce stade et josé on a
beaucoup dit que les 16 qui sont
maintenant 14 circonscriptions du npd au
québec les autres parties comme des
vautours tournent autour c'est un buffet
est évidemment c'est là qu'on voit à
quel point les chefs ça compte parce que
bon on n'a pas besoin de rappeler le
succès de jack layton au québec d'en
manquer qui avait quand même réussi à
sauver qu'il ait des immeubles et la jac
médecine pour le moment ça ne passe pas
on voit aussi dans sa publicité là où
ils enlèvent sont urbains ou ici fait de
la boxe où il se montre aussi sensible à
l'identité québécoise
ils veulent il veut se battre au québec
mais la question que tout le monde pose
avec raison c est ce que c'est pas trop
tard pour s'occuper du québec et
l'importance du québec ont le sortie
aussi ce dans tout dossier de la
lécithine le projet de loi 21 les partis
fédéraux marche sur des oeufs
monsieur trudeau début a dit qu'il était
content mais là le sait vraiment on se
tait on ne remet pas en question
il est libéral fédéral pourrait aider
des contestations 1-1 on sent un malaise
là d'ailleurs ce sera une des questions
pointues trudeau 1
mais c'est tout trouve être talonné
n'allait débat là dessus parce qu'il y
aurait là mais à cette élection là s'il
garde le pouvoir est ce que là il va
changer de discours mais pour le moment
on voit que les tous les chefs la
j'exclus bloc évidemment par définition
tous les chefs sont vraiment très
sensible à cette question là parce que
la loi 21
elle est très populaire dans l'électorat
francophone au québec
donc on ne peut rien dire et on voit
dans les médias canadiens
la gazette il ya déjà des commentateurs
sont en furie contre quelque chose
imaginez si c'était pierre elliott
trudeau je pense que lui se serait
exprimé plus durement
ouais mais là vraiment là on fait
attention au biscione le québec on veut
pas vraiment on veut pas éveillé ddd
vieux démons sur la question de
l'identité de la laïcité se ses claques
la recette on s'attache sur le mode du
bateau pour ne pas parler de sauter dans
l'arène je pense que monsieur trudeau il
va pas audible mais queen cette semaine
je pense que bien ça va être une des
questions qui va être posée parce que je
pense pas qu'ils vont ils vont ils vont
laisser passer le projet de loi 21 e ya
deux professeurs qui se font maintenant
pas engagé au québec parce qu'ils
refusent de porter des de ne pas porter
leurs signes religieux ça fait les
manchettes partout alors c'est une
question très vives
il aimerait bien mais ce trou d'où pas
en parler parce que justement le québec
est tellement clés à sa victoire
potentielle louis blouin vous serez donc
vous êtes ottawa vous allez non
êtes-vous à taïwan oui oui vous êtes un
témoin vous allez vous rendre à
trois-rivières à trois rivières on parle
de l'importance du terrain québécois à 3
rien que le chef conservateur andrew
scheer
oui monsieur celle qui veut clairement
envoyé un message il commence à trois
rivières c'est symbolique pour lui un
endroit où il veut faire des gains ça
fait partie de ces circonscriptions il y
aura des courses à 3 lente et libéraux
les conservateurs et les blocs comme à
droite par exemple comme à saint
hyacinthe bagot toutes d'anciennes
circonscription a fait des
circonscriptions actuellement sont
détenus par les néo démocrates alors
monsieur chiffre va envoyer ce message
laxiste important pour lui qu'il a
besoin du québec pour former le prochain
gouvernement tout comme la grande région
de toronto d'ailleurs deuxième arrêt de
la journée dans le point de woodbridge
et devant monsieur chez eux dans cette
circonscription là où il va ce soir il
ya une possibilité de gain il veut
essayer d'aller rechercher des
circonscriptions aux libéraux que ce
soit d'un coin de mississauga également
peut-être brenton aussi c'est que tout
se passe vraiment dans ce coin et là
vous voyez que derrière nous ça commence
à s'activer via l'avion qui est là sur
le tarmac est bien en évidence sur la
queue de l'avion
vous avez le fameux slogan plus qu'on
vous dès maintenant monsieur scheer qui
veut tenter de faire de la question du
coût de la vie vraiment l'élément
central de cette campagne là la question
de l'urne le 21 octobre prochain
il a quand même plusieurs défis devant
lui monsieur chiffres c'est sa première
campagne comme chef fédéral comme ça il
est peut-être moins expérimentés
monsieur scheer que peut l'être justin
trudeau en campagne en débats sont
françaises que ce sera un problème on
verra bien mais en tout cas ce sera
intéressant bien point de presse déjà de
primes ce que plus tard patrice 9h20
9h30 pour deviner qu'il commentera
sûrement les derniers développements
dans ces révélations pour la ville
anglaise procès concernant l'affairé
celle-ci laval est la grc qui aurait pas
eu accès à tous les témoins tous les
documents qu'elle soit à cause la
confidentialité du cabinet alors déjà on
sent qu'il veut envoyer des flèches
monsieur le but de saisir l'occasion de
tuer tu veux pas perdre une seconde
c'est clair que monsieur chien va
vouloir rappeler la sphère snc lavalin à
chaque fois qu'il aura un micro devant
lui juste une une précision aussi pour
les gens ont dit les nouveaux et c'est
vrai vous avez tout à fait raison de le
dire
c'est sa première campagne électorale
comme chef mêlée c'est un vieux mais
malgré son jeune âge c'est un vieux
députés y ait là dedans regina
qu'appelle depuis 2004 il a été le plus
jeune président de la chambre des
communes
donc il fait partie des meubles à ottawa
à la chambre des communes meilleurs ils
étaient plus discrets ils étaient plus
discrets avant de devenir chef
merci beaucoup monsieur chère que sa
femme un flair politique mais
l'expérience sur le terrain les ans pour
rencontrer les gens des impôts est
intéressant d'observer sur le terrain et
on nous dit dans les événements qu'on
veut organiser on veut le rapprocher des
gens on aura pas de rassemblement avec
le grand drapeau aussi souvent que la
dernière fois que monsieur un peu en
en 2015 on veut y aller vraiment sur des
événements où il va cogner à la porte
avec les gens les bénévoles des
barbecues et ses terres on va voir ça
beaucoup pas dans la cave
très bien alors bonne campagne vous on
va vous se reparler très souvent merci
beaucoup et puis au npd on le disait
c'est vraiment une bataille pour la
survie c'est sûr ça fait dramatiquement
tout cas il ya une glissade
on se demande jusqu'où ça va aller
christian noël bonjour à vous vous allez
donc suivre le npd vous êtes à london en
ontario london qui est parfois un
terreau fertile les députés
néo-démocrates la région ont des acquis
ici et jack médecine peut essayer de
protéger
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont s'attend ce qui
passe beaucoup de temps en ontario
durant cette campagne la wii dans la
région de toronto ou le npd a été rayé
de la carte en 2015 par une vague
libérale alors qu'ils avaient quelques
députés à toronto dans 9 05 la banlieue
toronto où on espère que
la nationalité de monsieur jack médecine
singh lui donne des des coudées franches
dans ces régions là pour aller chercher
les votes dans les circonscriptions
multiethnique mais le npd vote aussi en
ontario mise beaucoup sur les régions
ouvrière comme windsor nom de nous je me
trouve
oshawa là où le support néo démocrate
est actuellement sans et a su assez
actuellement assez fort qui s'est un peu
effondré avec la vague libérale de 2015
mais les néo démocrates malgré la
glissade dans les sondages malgré les
problèmes de financement qu'ils
éprouvent compte sur le terrain profitez
de la force du npd provincial ici en
ontario qui représente l'opposition
officielle qui se bat tous les jours
contre d'autres font le gouvernement
conservateur il espère maintenant que
cette opposition officielle qui s'est
construit une bonne machine sur le
terrain les aidera à passer par dessus
les obstacles auxquels il faut face
présentement et josy faisait référence
tout à l'heure à ces publicités pour le
terrain du québec ou au jack milk jack
médecine à jouer sur sa différence en
disant je vous comprends j'ai différents
canada moi aussi j'ai dû me battre pour
exprimer ma différence alors on verra
dans quelle mesure ce message ne va pas
assez mais donc le défi est énorme c'est
le moins que l'on puisse dire
s'intéressant au manitoba hier on le
voit le npd qui est le parti
d'alternance labo des libéraux sont à
peu près inexistants je sais pas si ça
va profiter à ce point one [ __ ] fédéral ce
sera à voir
christian bonne campagne à vous
à vous aussi
julie marchessault vous êtes avec le
bloc québécois vous allez donc sillonner
le québec et le bloc on le disait on l'a
dit depuis plusieurs semaines ce soir
regaillardi en tout cas et le chef y est
même allé d'une un objectif de doubler
la députation de 10 à 20 on verra mais
en tout cas on veut montrer que on va
vers le haut que la traversée du désert
est terminée absolument qu'on a mis lé
les chicanes de famille de côté si vous
voulez qu'on est vraiment réunies
derrière le chef voudrait même que dans
les dernières semaines il a même parlé
de tripler la députation alors voilà
pour les objectifs du chef là je me
trouve dans le local de christiane
gagnon à québec alors ça démarre
tranquillement l'on attend les candidats
de québec
ici on voulait en fait marquer le coup
devant l'assemblée nationale
il pleut des cordes patrice à québec
donc on a décidé plus tôt de faire ça
devant le local
l'idée pour le bloc québécois est le
message qui va être martelé tout au long
de cette campagne c'est nous sommes le
véritable parti qui peut représenter les
intérêts du québec
alors le québec c'est nous la laïcité
c'est nous l'énergie propre c'est nous
c'est ce qu'on voit sur les pancartes
c'est ce qu'on voit dans les publicités
également du bloc québécois et on ne se
cache au parti de viser le vote
francophone nationaliste donc dix
députés actuellement bloc québécois
deux députés sortants essentiellement
sur la couronne nord couronne sud de
montréal
une circonscription montréal mais si
vous voulez on vise vraiment le vote
francophone dans le 4 5 0 et dans les
régions
la campagne officielle bloc québécois va
véritablement démarré dimanche
aujourd'hui si vous voulez on est au
local ensuite va y avoir un discours de
françois blanchet au centre des congrès
mais dimanche c'est le départ le
développement de la plateforme
électorale
on va dévoiler également l'autobus de la
campagne du bloc et d'ici là ben nous on
va devoir suivre le cheikh de jour en
jour pour ses activités bien sûr et
particularités on est décidés au bloc
cette fois-ci de plutôt que de miser sur
circonscription par circonscription
faire campagne sur des thèmes
alors là on est à québec démontré qu'on
représente l'identité québécoise les
valeurs québécoises et à partir de
dimanche ça va être par thème et dans
des lieux qui sont liées au thème et on
va commencer avec l'environnement alors
ça ça va être à suivre pour dimanche
pour ainsi ben écoutez ça démarre
tranquillement mais on attend évidemment
les militants du bloc québécois au cours
de la prochaine heure mais oui et tout à
fait heureux détails mais julie ils ont
fait leurs cartes et il ya des
circonscriptions qui pointent d'abord
belle un chablis celle du chef ou le
présent et ça montre bien qu'on va aller
chercher ce que le npd avait au québec
que l'on veut aller faire des gains
importants dans ces circonscriptions là
vous parlez des vautours est autour des
circonscriptions du npd le bloc ne veux
absolument aller retrouver certains des
bastions qui est épais qui vous parlez
de beloeil chambly où se présentait
effectivement le chef du bloc québécois
on peut penser à berthier maskinongé par
exemple abitibi témiscamingue
évidemment on va compter aussi sur la
machine péquiste dans certaines
circonscriptions avignon la mitis matane
matapédia par exemple donc la
circonscription pascal bérubé dans la
région gaspésienne ou ne veut pas
traiter que je sais qu il est vrai
absolument que le pq avait eu plus de
60% des voix donc toute la machine de
pascal bérubé qui se met en branle
donc ça mais le bloc bien on verra mais
évidemment l'idée est de maintenir les
acquis où ils sont actuellement et de
faire des gains à ce que ce sera deux ce
que ce sera trop est ce que ce sera 10
est-ce que ce soit 15 de plus ça
évidemment c'est entre les mains des
électeurs
le bloc je voudrais par parent lyon pour
l'instant au niveau de la confiance des
candidats très bien je
alors bonne campagne avouant compte sur
vous donc tout au long de cette campagne
merci beaucoup
michel ces objets bonjour ça va bien
alors faire un petit tour parce que vous
allez faire l'émission spéciale à la
radio mais on vous a demandé de nous un
café on prend un café ensemble hier
journée de tant d'autres par ben on sera
en spéciale à partir de 10h celui ci
provient donc si les gens on va quitter
la clé des fois ça pourrait arriver il
faut continuer que ça très bien
vous aviez l'air au panel on sème là
vous aviez repris ce qu'on a dit tout à
l'heure aussi la majorité minorité va
peut-être décidé au québec mais la
couleur de ce gouvernement à leur faut
quand même pas oublier l'ontario des
attaches à autour de toronto la
trentaine de circonscriptions
si les conservateurs en rafle beaucoup
ils peuvent peut-être espérer avoir un
minoritaire et 9,05 scellé le code
régional qui est la grande banlieue de
toronto comme l'a450 à montréal ces deux
régions à surveiller parce que
effectivement la grande banlieue de
toronto d'habitude fait ou défait les
gouvernements faudra pas oublier qu'ils
vont avoir quelques pertes libéral dans
les maritimes
on frappe à 30 2 132 un autre fois c'est
comme derrière 6,49 deux fois de suite
ça sert à ça il 4 5 0 à montréal est
intéressant parce que il ya beaucoup
d'anciennes circonscription une [ __ ] qui
sont restés le bloc les yeux dessus sur
quel transfert de vente se fait pas
nécessairement d'eux
du npd aux blacks qui se fait plus de
bleu à bleus mais ça c'est une autre
histoire
donc il faut faire surveiller le 14 août
ouvert les verts même où ce sera
intéressant de voir ce que dans tel va
réussir à s'imposer
et ça c'est une possibilité mais il
reste que cette région là que la caq
balayé lors des dernières élections ce
que le bloc est vrai c'est que le bleu
caquistes se transforme en bleu
bloquiste faudra voir mais c'est ce qui
rend la campagne intéressante au québec
et sur les thèmes michel bon
l'environnement vers ce pétrole énergie
appelez ça comme vous voulez voir
peut-être pas s'imposer comme le thème
mais sera un thème incontournable
ça va être un très bon quand on aime ça
peut s'imposer comme le thème les
changements climatiques les gens sont
beaucoup plus enclins à en parler
aujourd'hui qui leur est qu'ils
l'avaient été par exemple à l'époque où
le studio mais déjà proposé une taxe sur
le carbone gic
on est premier en twitter encore on
n'est pas dans le même monde alors ça
c'est un thème et c'est un thème qui est
aussi porte division régionale des prêts
les trois mauvaises de crédit qui sont
extrêmement bleu conservateur ca grande
partie à cause de ce thème là faudra
voir quel est l'effet de saussure
material québec entendre l'ontario
encore ça peut diviser votre justement
dans le neuf 056 indivise de votre
progressiste environnementales entre les
autres partis autres que les
conservateurs ça pourrait profiter aux
conservateurs comme ça fait en 2011 pour
monsieur harper quand le vote était très
fort et était appris des votes des
libéraux et à diviser le vote fn paie
des libéraux et même un peu vain
conservateur pas exactement madeleine
blé morin bonjour à vous vous êtes
toronto ce magnifique terrain
résidence de la gouverneure générale
alors on le disait l'environnement va
certainement s'imposer bien d'autres
sujets importants on ce matin le globe
on reparle de la sphère snc lavalin donc
il y aura des questions d'éthique comme
le chiot voudra mettre à l'avant-plan
etc etc
c'est difficile de dessiner ce que sera
cette campagne avant qu qu'on la bible
oui et parfois on réalise que c'est les
sujets qu'on n'a pas vu venir finalement
qui sont déterminants dans les campagnes
souvenez vous de 2015 c'était toute la
question du niqab qui avait finalement
complètement jeté en l'air les plans du
parti néo-démocrate qui a dû essayer de
s'adapter et finalement ça a été très
très difficile pour le npd
mais on peut quand même regarder ce qui
se passe au point de départ il ya toute
la question de la fiscalité mais aussi
elle est le coût de la vie pour les
consommateurs pour la classe moyenne
on sent que le parti conservateur veut
que vous en ayez et vous en ayez plus
dans vos poches
mais le parti libéral aussi veut essayer
de d'apaiser les craintes
la classe moyenne quant à la façon de
boucler leurs fins de mois donc on veut
voir de quelle façon leur politique
s'articule à ce sujet là il ya la
question d'environnement
cette fois ci on sent que c'est un enjeu
sans avait été un en 2008 souvenez-vous
société la campagne que seuil est de
mener stéphane dion à l'époque il y
avait son fameux plan vert à l'époque
mais on avait eu des tourments
économiques et les citoyens les
contribuables s'était finalement
retourné sur des questions davantage
économique
alors ces enjeux là il bouge durant la
campagne s'est passé peau stable s'est
pas fixé d'avancé
les parties ont beau faire des plans il
faut aussi qu'on vérifie au cours des 4
40 prochains jours quelle est leur
flexibilité
à quel point ils sont capables de
s'adapter parce que c'est comme ça aussi
qu'on va être capable de juger de la
capacité d'un parti à gouverner un pays
parce que c'est aussi d'être capable de
faire face à des enjeux rapidement très
bien madame vous restez là donc je
rappelle mesdames et messieurs que
justin trudeau
on l'a vu tout à l'heure à les
reconduire ses enfants à l'école sera
donc à l'arrêt
dans un gouverneur général vers 10
heures pour demander la dissolution de
la chambre des communes et donc la
campagne commencera ce moment là il va
ressortir faire le premier point de
presse de la campagne électorale et les
autres chefs vont parler en cascade on
va bien évidemment vous présenter tous
les points de presse ce matin
on aura le temps d'analyser ce qu'ils
ont dit pénalisé aussi on a déjà
commencé vous donner une idée de haut va
se jouer
cette campagne électorale donc pour le
21 octobre michel avant de vous laisser
aller à la radio il ya aussi d'autres
questions par exemple l'immigration se
demande est ce que c'est vraiment une
préoccupation ou pomme monsieur bernier
voudrait s'en soit un nom le vu monsieur
bernier peut-être un du centac sic
maxime bernier vont prendre une question
comme l'environnement comme il l'a fait
de façon très très durs comme avec
breton a mais les migrations qu'il
pourrait rendre soit acceptée dire si
vous touchez à l'immigration vous êtes
dans le cas de maxime bernier ça ça
risque de rendre les acteurs rend
difficile pour répartir vous cherchez
par exemple d'essayer d'en faire un
enjeu
il ya des choses importantes qui se
passe au pays notre relation avec la
chine par exemple il ya eu des accords
commerciaux de signer importants qui ont
une influence sur nos vies on passe avec
l'europe
le nouvel aréna est ce que ces questions
là vont émerger ou bien bons d'achat je
vous vois rocher c'est pas là dessus que
les gens m'ont fortement les questions
de relations internationales de traiter
à même s'ils sont très importants à part
peut-être du libre échange en 98 quand
cité l'élection tournaire saut sur la
possibilité de l'accord ça ne touche pas
la personne moyenne c'est pas quelque
chose de déterminant
malheureusement pour les conservateurs
qui aimeraient faire tourner au ridicule
la présence de monsieur trudeau à
l'international
mais est ce que ça va changer
vat je pense que ceux qui jouent pour
monsieur trudeau par exemple en affaires
internationales
c'est le fait qu'on a finalement conclu
un nouvel aréna et que malgré ce qu'a
essayé de faire le chemin des îles c'est
maïsano ça ne veut rien donner cette
négociation là il ya des conservateurs
qui était dans le comité aviseur du
gouvernement dans l'agro entre autres
ont dit non non le très bien fait ça et
tout le monde comprend que avoir à
s'occuper d'un autre homme c'est un
enjeu à plein table le gouvernement et
qu'il s'en est tiré le mieux qu'il le
pouvait il est même s'il veut se shirdi
il a mal négocié car monsieur marc ronet
félicite monsieur trudeau sa voix même
sujet en porte-à-faux un peu la wii est
la question que les gens vont se
demander c'est ce qu'aime rauscher est
vraiment fait mieux que justin trudeau
site est souvent le même siège
la réponse est probablement non donc on
peut pas gagner de points pour accrocher
avec cette question là vous savez les
canadiens ont tous un peu chauvin et on
veut bien paraître sur la scène
internationale en vue que nos chefs
promène pic soit appréciée mais en
réalité le porc canadien dans les
grandes affaires du monde est assez
faible et donc c'est pas nous qui allons
décider de l'avenir de la planète c'est
pas comme aux etats-unis où le président
lorsqu'il était lui un énorme impact sur
la planète tout le monde suisse dont le
boiteux pays du g7 et du g20 suis pas
certain que les canadiens ont conscience
à quel point on n'est peut-être pas un
joueur très important
inévitablement sa fonction quand je vois
des campagnes électorales ou à
l'étranger
non non il est aussi je pense que le
début du mandat de justin trudeau là où
il dit est devenu un club trop terne
oui mais physiquement il est il était
littéralement partout et c'était une
vedette une star partent en asie les
seules fois où janot philippe et noir
alors il reste que la base libérale au
delà des débats peut-être un petit peu
plus complètes sur les relations
internationales
il reste que ce souvenir est encore
l'heure il n'existe plus dans le présent
on
justin trudeau n'est plus la rockstar
qui est accueilli avec des
applaudissements et des femmes qui
pleurent quand hilary mais il
mais il y a il a eu cette force là donc
oui peut-être que monsieur chère peut
ramener les livres mais les libéraux
peuvent ramener ou aussi des souvenirs
disons sur la scène internationale un
peu plus agréable je sais où j'ai je
vous libère vous allez faire votre
émission de radio merci on se revoit va
très bientôt ce soir ce soir ils soir de
l'élection avec d'aussi bonnes émissions
pollution à vous le rend ce partage est
à victoria l'autre le ton sur 20 c'est
la lutte pour la 2e à la 3e place la
libéraux conservateurs vont se battre
pour le pouvoir
soyons francs ensuite le npd qui luttent
on l'a dit tout à l'heure pour sa survie
et les verts qui qui veulent monter qui
veulent prendre la place du npd comme
conscience verte au canada vous êtes
avec la chef elizabeth may oui
absolument et l'hiver voulons dit on n'a
jamais eu autant d'attention autant
d'attention médiatique qu'en ce moment
alors elizabeth may qui lance sa
campagne ici à victoria sur l'île de
vancouver où se trouve sa
circonscription donc on va vous montrer
patrice en ce moment vous allez voir
c'est quand même assez tranquille il
faut dire qu il est 6 heures du matin en
ce moment colombie britannique
mais c'est intéressant donc cette île de
vancouver et à 6 circonscriptions en ce
moment il y en a deux qui sont détenus
par les verts 4 par le npd
les verts espèrent faire des gains
est-il d'ailleurs il avec neuf a passé
beaucoup de temps à colombie britannique
durant cette campagne
elle va aussi aller en atlantique dans
les provinces maritimes au québec vous
avez parlé de pierre nantel le vert
l'hiver peut être faire des gains de ce
côté là madame blue mais qui va être le
27 septembre à montréal à la marche sur
le climat et donc son slogan est
intéressant on dit ni à droite ni à
gauche mais vers l'avant ensemble donc
on veut rassembler autour de l'enjeu de
l'environnement mais le défi pour les
verts dans cette campagne c'est de
montrer que il ya autre chose finalement
que la plateforme environnementale qu'on
a tout un programme
un programme
et ça c'est intéressant ni à droite ni à
gauche donc on veut se présenter comme
centriste parce que oui par exemple on
est pour le revenu minimum garanti mais
en même temps on veut revenir à
l'équilibré budgétaire d'ici cinq ans un
peu comme les conservateurs
donc est ce que ce sera des questions
qui vont plaire aux canadiens c'est ce
qu'espère elizabeth may qui veut faire
campagne patrice en voiture électrique
quand elle peut en bus on essaie de
trouver un bus électrique mais si on
nous a dit que c'était pas évident en
avion quand ils le font aussi en train
et quand elle prend l'avion il avait
tenu on nous a dit qu'elle allait
acheter ces crédits pour le quart ben
ouais c'est plus difficile de venir en
bateau comme cette jeune lambert parce
que la géographie du canada faire
l'avion est un peu et qu'on tourne à
pour faire campagne pour le parti vert
ouais mais bon bien elle est furieuse en
faisons petite parenthèse quand même là
dessus elle est furieuse parce que comme
vous savez madame et messieurs il ya
deux débats organisés par la commission
des débats une nouvelle commission qui
en voulait aux visées au gouvernement
faire le ménage parce que la dernière
fois en 2015 a pas eu de débat
anglophone parce que monsieur ne voulait
pas la cbi si bref ya une commission tv
organise en parallèle pour le québec
pour le marché québécois leur famille
face à face et ils n'ont pas évité les à
bétheny et là elle est en colère et le
des colères par ce qu'a dit les sondages
montrent qu'au québec je suis
compétitives entre guillemets en tout
cas autant que le npd ou presque ça
c'est une occasion de moins pour elle
pour se faire valoir
oui absolument puis vous parlez des
sondages on l'a vu un vraiment depuis le
début de l'année elle a commencé le
parti vert était au niveau national
autour de 6 7% à 5 si on fait la moyenne
des sondages
là on est plus autour de 10 11% donc
vous le disiez c'est la bataille
peut-être pour la la troisième place qui
se joue entre le npd et les verts entre
qu'en ce début de campagne et madame y
dimassi je ne peux pas présenter mes
idées comment est ce que je peux
convaincre
très bien merci beaucoup on va suivre
donc cette campagne des verts et puis
sébastien saint françois nous terminons
cette tournée de nos journalistes qui
seront avec les chefs il ya maxime
bernier
débat lui est un furet comme tout le
monde parce que la commission non plus
ne l'a pas entre jusqu'ici invités
contenus qu'ils ne répondent pas aux
trois critères d'avoir élu un député de
faire d'avoir de bonnes chances de faire
élire quelques députés et lui il a un
des trois critères s'agit là des
candidats d'à peu près toutes les
circonscriptions alors lui voit lancer
sa campagne
monsieur bernier en ontario où elle va
répondre au lancement de la campagne par
la visite du centre d'o'shea gouvernance
générale cet après midi à 13h30 hae
tobiko monsieur bernier a déjà d'une
certaine manière lancé sa campagne il ya
plus d'une semaine là
en bourse mais dans les faits il va être
à toronto aujourd'hui ce dernier va être
en ontario à de nombreuses reprises
patrice au cours des prochains jours des
prochaines semaines du mois de septembre
si ce que son organisation m'a confirmé
il était à l'aune d'une hier soir où
notre collègue christian noël se
trouvait avec le npd
on espère peut-être qu'ici aller
chercher les votes de ce côté-là il a
été faire une visite à belleville belvès
et la région immédiate de trenton la
plus grande base aérienne des forces
canadiennes au pays a déjà fait ces
visites la sera à toronto aujourd'hui
reviendra au minimum vers la fin du mois
pour aller à hamilton qui est un creuset
je vous dirais du npd un peu aussi comme
landon donc très clairement monsieur
bernier a des visées pour l'ontario est
ce que ça va se traduire en sièges sur
une question qui est toujours ouverte
monsieur bernier n'est très loin dans
les intentions de vote au niveau
national soyons clairs mais on sent
qu'il a un oeil sur l'ontario et sa peau
pour rien
l'ontario ses 120 1 plus de 120 sièges
55 sièges dans la région immédiate du
grand toronto le grand toronto pèse plus
lourd que certaines provinces par
exemple des maritimes sans vouloir
insulter personne sur l'échiquier du
nombre de députés partout au pays donc
monsieur bernier il espère faire
certaines percer ici
hier il était à london il est revenu sur
certains des grands thèmes de sa
campagne et de ce que son parti veut
représenter veut diminuer la taille de
l'état fédéral veut privatiser la
société des postes veut diminuer
l'immigration à 150 mille personnes par
année
on se doute qu'il va répéter ces thèmes
là il aura aussi dans l'ontario mais
aujourd'hui et je termine as-tu patrice
maxime bernier il va souligner le début
de la campagne a été au big o est au big
o c koi basse et l'ancien fief de rob
ford fut le maire de toronto il sera
accompagné à ce moment là maxime bernier
de renata ford la veuve de rob ford
comme quoi on sent qu'il essaiera
d'aller jouer dans l'état et
conservatrice en ontario est ce que ça
donnera des résultats
pour l'instant la question de jours
ouverte le problème qu'il a c'est que
les conservateurs en ontario pour
l'instant n'arrache pas mal dans
l'opinion publique
les gens ont déchanté un peu devant des
plans de compressions ta choc pour nous
en parler davantage merci bonne campagne
à vous merci mon ne le suivra pas
partout faut quand même le préciser mais
aujourd'hui en tout cas vous serez avec
lui merci beaucoup
sébastien et en beauce d'abord il en
premier défi parce que le candidat
conservateur de l'ancien maire louis qui
collaborent activement au très populaire
très connus producteurs agricoles donc
toute la question de la gestion de
l'offre qui compte beaucoup en beauce
or cette maxime bernier veut abolir la
gestion de l'offre en matière
d'agriculture dans c'est ce qui lui a
coûté la chefferie
mais si c'est ce qui lui a certainement
coûté 1 du moins les votes dans son
propre comté lors de la chefferie le
saas est assez clair et mon maxime
gagnon le voile actuellement dans les
projections de sièges dans les sondages
le coup on est au coude à coude entre
les conservateurs richard lehoux et
maxime bernier donc je devrais garder un
oeil quand même sur la bo cela peut bien
se promener en ontario peut le faire le
tour du pays mais faut d'abord que pour
son parti surveillé qu'il assure une
présence à la chambre des communes il
faut qu'il garde son propre siège et les
majorités d'antan sont loin d'être
acquise pour l'huile actuellement là ça
va chauffer pour mâles en beauce il
partirait ne sert aux kings présentent
un maxime bernier aussi qu'elle même ne
suis pas une tête qui va reprendre son
single
mais ce qu'on voit aussi chez maxim
bernis et que un autre handicap qui peut
avoir dans la beauce c'est que c'est
beaucoup discrédité dans les dernières
semaines avec des déclarations le
intempestives rétrograde même la sortie
son souhait pro environnement opole
jeudi c'était vraiment très personnel ça
peut être un handicap il l'ontario ça
c'est intéressant parce que quand tout
ça parlait du populisme
moi je pense que le populisme au canada
ça reste marginal comme courage et c'est
probablement pour ça que d'autres ford
étant très justement de prendre une
débâcle a donc oui il est c'est parce
que maxime bernis le populiste à la
puissance 10 le quand même là c'est
l'ultime c'est l'omni populiste donc il
essaie de s'accrocher après la famille
ford
mais comme vous disiez tout à l'heure ce
n'est plus les bons jours non plus de ce
côté là mais y'a pas beaucoup il n'y a
pas beaucoup de choix et la preuve
regardez où il est dans les sondages
pour le moment il est dans la marge
d'erreur la nuit et à deux trois jours
sa tâche elle connaissait bien qu'en
pensez vous mais je pense que françois
legault
moi je pense pas de françois legault
sont impopulaires je connais max bernier
j'avais jamais travaillé à l'essai
économique de montréal après qu'il soit
parti et
je ne comprends pas maxime bernier
aujourd'hui je serai honnête avec son
virement
c'est quelque chose qui dont il parlait
pas sur des questions d'immigration sur
les questions les attaques personnelles
le comportement je dirais plus surtout
eto'o et ailleurs qui présente n'est pas
là c'est maxime bernier je sais plus
comme on avait essayé de faire deux cas
les litiges pendants la course
conservatrice tout d'un coup elle a
parlé de politique vraiment de très très
droite qui n'était pas dans son décor
avance est ce que c'est un calcul
électoraliste
je pense que oui est-ce que ça va porter
fruit je suis d'accord avec josy que aux
matériaux les conservateurs ont perdu
des plumes c'est sûr presse en danger à
cause des compressions
c'est à cause du fait qu'on pense que
d'oxford c'est parce qu'il fait il mais
d'aider des renversements il se renverse
sur plusieurs dossiers de jours à jour
et il ya sûrement de demande de
compétences de gestion alors ça ça
ternit son image lui c'est un problème
pour les conservateurs moins qu'un atout
pour maxi bernis le problème pour les
courses moyen de chez eux parce qu'on
connaît que les deux filets en
visionnant est-ce qu'on veut ça au
fédéral
parce que ce que vous dites en 2006 que
maxime bernier n'est plus beaucoup pris
au sérieux dans les cirques conservateur
en tout cas qu'il voulait c'est du visa
c'est aussi ça c'est plus laisser les
cercles d'extrême droite je passe lors
il le regarde comme un champion ce qui
me déçoit beaucoup personnellement bon
répond quand on regarde les sondages
internes du parti conservateur il ya
pourtant de transfert vers maxime
bernier maxime bernier attire une
clientèle qui ne votent pas
habituellement qui s'est fâché conclu
pour qu'ils y localiser les comptes
limiter la gêne est il actuellement
c'est ce qu'il va chercher ce qui peut
le faire grandir cette tente le
suffisamment pour commencé à gruger dans
les conservateurs il le pot fait jusqu'à
présent mais le 4 3 4 5% qu'il détient
dans les sondages actuellement c'est
probablement des gens qui seraient
restés à la maison ce maxime bernier
n'existait pas donc je qui ne nuit pas
non aux autres partir au jeu vous
remonte mesdames et messieurs les images
de justin trudeau ce matin il était à
deux heures du déclenchement des
élections est allé reconduire on va les
voir d'art et voilà il est allé
reconduire ses enfants l'école donc la
vie
d'une famille qu'il veut projeter comme
il le fait il souvent j'en ai aucune
idée
on lui demandera mais c'est quand même
intéressant comme image parce qu'en
politique tout est calculé les caméras
let lol bon alors c'est l'image qu'il
essaie de projeter c'est premièrement
regarder le à quel point il est relax on
dirait qu'ils s'en vont chercher un café
ou thé moteur alors il est relax i marsh
la maille est avec sa famille avec ses
enfants donc je suis premier ministre je
suis en contrôle un homme de famille je
suis pas stressé j'ai pas de resto c'est
vraiment une image très frappante est là
et ce qu'ils essaient de communiquer à
mon avis et ça c'est je suis en contrôle
et cette campagne leur va bien se passer
pour nous et libéraux luberon sont parce
que moi voir des choses et aussi la
présence de sophie grégoire parce que sa
fille grégoire ont aussi depuis
plusieurs mois elle était comme c'est
paru du radar est long on apprend aussi
qu'elle voit qu'elle a son enfant une
présence importante au québec parce que
ça figure et gloire quand même c'est
quelqu'un qui ont aussi dû tirant d'eau
campbell à elle et elle est comme son
mari elle elle est très affable elle
quand elle rentre dans une pièce avec
les aussi auprès des jeunes filles et
des femmes dans tout à fait donc la
présence de sophie grégoire n'est pas
non plus maïs on veut montrer l'unité on
va l'être et le calme on veut montrer la
famille c'est parce que je l'avais sorti
en vidéo la première journée 2-2 du
scolaire avec ses enfants qui faisait le
petit déjeuner chez lui alors toute la
question de la famille c'est très
important pour les conservateurs jouer
sur cet aspect de famille ils libéreront
je pense joue aussi là dessus pour
contrer l'image que justin trudeau c'est
le flamboyant tient à l'international le
cover boy tout ça il essaie de montrer
nos seins père de famille aussi le
regarderai avec ses enfants regardent ce
qu'il fait alors je pense que c'est ce
freeware sous la dent aussi parce que
nous perdons dans quel esprit sont les
stratèges libéraux actuellement à ce
qu'ils se disent vos missions fait mots
s'il ya pas d prévu majeurs sont fait
pas de grosses gaffes ont pu au pire au
propre tête être minoritaire mais perdre
le pouvoir ce serait étonnant ce qu'ils
se disent ni on est beaucoup plus
confiant maintenant qu'on l'était au
printemps car la chambre s'est raffermi
et vous voyez d'ailleurs dans les vidéos
qu'on a qui ont déterré chez les
libéraux le n 2 chez eux sur le mariage
gay ensuite mes ruches sur l'éducation
indochine sur toutes sortes de sujets
les coupures éventuelle d'un
gouvernement de nos chiens on sent que
le bon coup électoral des libéraux est
active depuis plusieurs semaines et ils
ont consenti un petit peu de feu quand
même en tuent des pieds on était abattus
désorienté chez les libéraux printemps
on avait connu un hiver extrêmement
difficile long laissant beaucoup plus d'
attaque alors comme on dit souvent cette
campagne là normalement devrait leur
appartenir il devrait aller chercher un
deuxième mandat s'il la perd ça va être
de leur faute
alors on les sent confiant mais en même
temps ils savent qu'il ya certaines
régions du pays une côte à remonter ça
va brasser pas mal en colombie
britannique au québec
on en ontario donc une relative
confiance chez les stratèges libéraux à
qui j'ai parlé mais 40 jours il peut se
passe énormément de choses qu'on ne
voudra pas déplaire à qui on voudra pas
déplaire et on le dit depuis le début
c'est le premier ministre du québec
monsieur legault qui flotte sur un nuage
là qui vraiment il est dans une période
vraiment extraordinaire d'un niveau d'un
point de vue politique sébastien bovet
bonjour à vous alors on le disait plus
tôt je sais pas si vous étiez avec nous
vous avez entendu nous avons entendu
mais par exemple sur la laïcité même si
par nature monsieur trudeau voudrait
dire je suis archi contre ça je veux
même aider des gens à aller devant les
tribunaux les droits individuels c'est
sacré pour moi pour mon père etc
on n'a rien entendu de son ne veut pas
froisser l'électorat québécois il
premier ministre le goût et ses
illustres le grand écart auquel vont
devoir le que les chefs de partis
fédéraux vont devoir faire dans cette
campagne parce qu au québec contre leurs
positions dans le reste du canada leur
position québec tant que la laïcité
ce sera ça fera peut-être pas partie de
la liste de demandes de françois legault
enfin ça m'étonnerait beaucoup à part ça
monsieur legault doit faire ces demandes
la semaine prochaine il avait prévu
faire ça cette semaine mais on a
repoussé à la semaine prochaine parce
que d'un calendrier il ya déclenchement
aujourd'hui c'est la journée des chefs
de mails la cac et en caucus
donc on ramène ça la semaine prochaine
donc dans sa liste de demandes seront
probablement pas la laïcité mais la
laïcité va s'inviter dans le débat et
les chefs vont par la bande devoir
prendre position sur cette question là
justin trudeau est très contre on la loi
québécoise on le sait monsieur shirdi
c'est la prérogative du gouvernement du
québec de légiférer dans cette matière
là donc ils nous voient un peu alors ce
serait rappelez-vous de thomas mulcair
en 2015 je pense qu'ils avaient été pris
dans ce débat sur la laïcité donc ça
peut faire perdre des points aux chefs
fédéraux et ils seront certainement été
appelés sur cette question là pendant la
campagne électorale au québec très bien
rappelons les forces en présence de
sébastien au québec 40
je vous parle des résultats de 2015 40
libéraux 12 conservateur 16,1 de pda
ils sont maintenant 14 parce que
monsieur nantel comme vous savez quand
didot vert et monsieur walker a perdu et
a démissionné et les libérons repris
outremont et 10 pour le bloc québécois
ça c'est quand même la ligne de départ
la voici le paysage actuel
oui on a l'impression que ce qui est en
jeu c'est beaucoup les circonscriptions
du npd avec les libéraux les bloquistes
les verts qui ont des yeux sur ces
circonscriptions leurs pis les
conservateurs qui misent peut-être sur
le sentiment pourrait être l'alternative
enfin le sentiment entre un anti trudeau
anti libérale hop voilà un peu comment
on essaie de se diviser la tarte ici de
québec évidemment les les
les ministres les députés prendront pas
position officiellement dans la campagne
et en a eu un mot d'or monsieur leroy
dit que je les vois pas là que je le
vois pas prendre position qui veut pas
dire que monsieur legault aura pas des
demandes alors dans les demandes
on a parlé de la laïcité qui sera pas
nécessairement une demande formelle mais
dans les demandes formelles il pourrait
y avoir par exemple le financement de
projets d'infrastructures
le troisième-ligne ac est venu rappeler
qu'au cours des derniers jours monsieur
legault a brandi le spectre du péage sur
le troisième lien ci a pas de
financement fédéral de la structure puis
pendant de financement on ne sait pas
combien ça va coûter troisième hier les
estimé c'est entre 4 milliards et 10
milliards à ce moment donc il ya une
grande marge
et on a besoin du financement fédéral 1
du chiffre montre de l'ouverture justin
trudeau on sait pas trop ce qu'il en
pense
mais on va demander probablement aux
partis fédéraux de prendre position
là-dessus l'immigration aussi est-ce que
l'immigration deviendra un enjeu de
cette campagne électorale
t'es pas nécessairement mais au québec
il ya des questions que monsieur le
candidat au québec général pour pouvoir
avoir le pouvoir d'imposer le test des
valeurs le test de français aux nouveaux
arrivants qui est ici au québec au bout
de trois ans il a besoin du feu vert
d'ottawa justin trudeau il aime pas la
façon dont monsieur legault fait les
choses en immigration
indochine retourne reprend sa ligne de
tir
bon c'est la prérogative du gouvernement
du québec 2
ouvert dans son regard un peu plus de
pouvoir enfin il ouvre sur bon d'être
donné plus de pouvoir même si ce n'est
pas très précis alors l'immigration les
demandes du gouvernement du québec en
immigration on pourrait aussi faire
l'objet de la liste des piles pour être
se retrouver sur la liste d'épicerie le
monsieur legault sébastien merci
beaucoup on vous retrouve aux mordus
mais aussi mordu auront beaucoup à se
mettre sous la dent réglé aujourd'hui
c'est très bien à 16h merci beaucoup à
voir michelle breedt vous êtes à moncton
on l'a dit plus tôt je pense que c'est
un sujet qu'il utilisait l'expression à
la 6/49 c'est rare qu'on gagne deux fois
les libéraux ont rasé ont remporté
toutes les circonscriptions des
maritimes de l'atlantique 30 232 on
estime qu'on fera des pertes chez vous
lors quelque part mais c'était un score
parfait c'était du jamais vu qu'on est
toutes les circonscriptions du côté de
l'équipe libérale
alors évidemment ça avait été pour eux
une grande victoire mais ç'a changé
depuis 2015 quand même à l'époque les
libéraux semblent être la solution pour
défaire le gouvernement de stephen
harper on n'avait pas émis en trop que
d'aussi de la façon qu'on a déjà
gouvernement rappelait les gérer le
dossier de l'assurance-emploi là on
avait gagné toutes les circonscriptions
mais justin trudeau avait dit d'abord à
l'époque on prendra pas de l'atlantique
pour acquis donc il avait nommé deux
ministres on s'en rappelle juliette
petit pâté lieu à la santé et demie club
blanc à pêche hausse ayant par la suite
aux affaires intergouvernementales
il est venu souvent en acadie lors
d'événements aussi lors des inondations
étaient hier halifax pour les lendemains
de dorian donc qu'il a il est venu
souvent mais il y avait une époque où si
patrice vous vous en rappelez quatre
gouvernements provinciaux et c'est là
que je prends mon exemple quatre
gouvernements provinciaux qui était
aussi libéraux donc c'est l'effet rouge
partout en atlantique en 2015 il ya eu
des élections provinciales au
nouveau-brunswick d'abord les libéraux
ont été défaits les libéraux de gale ont
été défaits par les progressistes
conservateurs de brian de blaine higgs à
l'île du prince édouard les libéraux ont
été défaits les
progressistes-conservateurs ont gagné
les verts sont arrivés deuxièmes les
libéraux ont terminé bons troisièmes et
à terre-neuve les libéraux sont toujours
là sauf qu'ils sont minoritaires
donc ils inventent changement est aussi
des dossiers qui ont choqué un peu les
gens de l'atlantique le pipeline énergie
sk tombé à l'eau il ya des gens qui
tenait ce pipeline est aussi tout
dossier de la tarification du carbone
il ya blé n'dri au nouveau-brunswick le
premier ministre qui milite contre cette
tarification du carbone qui est souvent
très convaincre des électeurs qu'il faut
pas avoir cette tarification et on verra
le 21 octobre si tout ça ça va faire du
tort aux libéraux de justin trideau très
bien très clair michel web et les verts
en opposition officielle allait du
prince édouard intéressante que les
verts s'accrocha 110 ans on n'est pas
que du folklore on peut avoir une
présence significative dans le jeu
politique dans les provinces et au
canada cher merci bonne campagne à vous
et mesdames et messieurs je vous montre
une carte du canada puisque michel en a
parlé pour pour les maritimes pour
l'atlantique
mais il ya eu dix ans que monsieur
trudeau ses amis rouges en a plus
beaucoup la ière bayern avons
connaissent pas pour les libéraux
manitoba mais les conservateurs ont
repris le pouvoir
monsieur par leicester qui a inquiété
car emporté mais regardez la carte des
provinces d'achat il a pu il ya plus
beaucoup de cran libéraux annie allié
indéfectible de monsieur trudeau lé nom
et dans ce sens bizarre peut-être mais
sitôt un certain avantage en ontario en
particulier parce que doc ford c'est
l'anti trudeau il te positionnes contenu
fait campagne contre lui dans un certain
sens aussi quand on regarde en colombie
britannique c'est limpide et au
provincial
mais là monsieur trudeau de la lutte
c'est vraiment c'est à 3 alors est-ce
que ça profite à qui on libéraux ont
profité aux libéraux dans un certain
sens alors moi je suis pas convaincu qu
il est aussi misérable qu'il était sauf
que on se rappelle quand il était là en
campagne en 2015 et fait des grandes
promesses de remettre en ordre de la
fédération d'être le grand rassembleur
monsieur harper n'avait jamais des
réunions bon je sais pas la dernière
réunion des premiers sont qualifiés
trudeau a assisté ça fait quoi plus
qu'un an je pense alors il changeait
chance ça tourne un peu là dessus
oui ça il y avait beaucoup critiqué mais
sur harry à l'époque un homme sur un peu
snob les premiers ministres enfin nous
comme ça peut ne croyez pas assez grand
cirque de conférence fédérale
provinciale et répétable avait redonné
quand même de l'autonomie et des
pouvoirs ou province qui est certaine
alternance aussi qui se fait à
l'interview en particulier conservateur
au provincial libéral fédéral ou là et
verse reybier vient ajouter la dernière
rencontre des premiers ministres des
provinces avec le gouvernement canadien
est en décembre dernier à montréal
fameuse 2-4
françois legault sur l'énergie salle
louis leur froide il a raison c'est
qu'en politique on est aussi bon que
l'adversaire qu'on affronte ça prend des
adversaires fois capable de contraste et
ses politiques avec d'autres est lui
capable de se promener justin trudeau en
faisant campagne contre un dossier mais
peut faire campagne contre justine cani
peut le rencontrer
comme pour la loterie où il fera pas
campagne contre françois legault pas
comment sa lune de miel
mais ailleurs on est capable donc de
dire à ceux qui sont insatisfaits de
leur gouvernement provincial vous avez
une alternative au fédéral donc c'est un
produit que ça va l'avantager partout
mais je ne sais pas aussi difficile ou
misérable que la carte peut laisser
penser à l'inde à se démarquer
saleh doit se démarquer il apparaît plus
clairement avec ses propositions à lui à
lui et c'est clair que tout son
positionnement face à ben ce bleu
omniprésent ça va être le progressisme
bon le retour de surratt bottes soucis
dans son entourage auraient passé comme
inconnu comme comme conseiller à ces
progressistes
quand je parlais au début de l'émission
la de la vision plus collective de
monsieur trudeau où est plus
individualiste de monsieur chiffres
c'est un peu ça aussi
donc moi je pense que ça va se décliner
comme ça pour les libéraux pendant la
campagne
seul le seul chemin de la victoire pour
justin trudeau s'est coalisée le vote de
gauche
j'ai besoin de moi que ça reste le plus
faible possible
ils se diraient être le seul rempart
contre gouvernements conservateurs c'est
les réussissent heures et va gagner
l'élection
si les gens ont l'impression que leur
vote peut compter on va pas vraiment [ __ ]
oliva et que ça s'effrite à gauche le
bloc conservateur est tellement solide
que lui vole l'emporté sur la question
de l'environnement ou six parce que moi
je parle je parle de mes - josé des
images en direct touch yeux qui se
dirige pour prendre son avion qui vole
premier voyage de la campagne il va
prendre les questions va l'écouter la
justice et du bureau du premier ministre
et deuxièmement que justin trudeau fait
tout ce qu'il peut afin de bloquer cette
enquête
moi je fais appel à monsieur trudeau de
faire ce qui s'impose et de renoncer à
tous les privilèges pour que les
individus puissent témoigner devant un
gers est passé d' entrave à la justice
et deux que je trouve en bas tout faire
pour le bloquer alors je lui demande de
se lever
le privilège dès maintenant bonjour
radio canada qu'est ce que l'article du
globe & mail de ce matin à changer de
stratégie
réponse nous allons aux canadiennes ou
leurs dents à quel point monsieur
trudeau a induit en erreur les canadiens
il a menti carrément disant des choses
qu'il savait fausse et nous notre
commentaire c'est qu'il a perdu
l'autorité morale de gouverner donc dans
les cinq semaines à venir nous allons
présenter notre vision du pays
pour m que d'argent entre les mains des
canadiens pour qu'elle peut s'avancer
mais ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on ne peut tout simplement pas faire
confiance à justin trudeau
il devra n'importe quoi pour camoufler
ses scandales il fera n'importe quoi
pour se réunir et les canadiens ne
peuvent plus le croire
on l'a vu après le dépôt du rapport du
commissaire à l'éthique sa peau fait
beaucoup bouger l'aiguillé dans les
sondages pour monsieur trudeau qu'est ce
qui vous fait croire que ça peut être
différent cette fois-ci que ce qu'on
apprend ce matin c'est différent cette
seconde assez pâle question de l'impact
sur les sondages c'est une question de
l'intégrité de est-ce que je n'ai
trudeau l'autorité morale de continuer
de gouverner
et alors pendant les prochaines cinq
semaines est prêt et quelques jours je
vais à démontrer aux canadiens les
raisons pour lesquelles j'ai un trou
d'eau a perdu l'autorité morale de
continuer de gouverner et notre planète
rock alternatif de gouvernement qui va
revivre selon l'essai moyen de rajouter
plus de d'argent dans les poches des
canadiennes lorsqu'il peut admirer le
quotidien alors ça c'est notre message
et je suis sûr que notre message va
résonner avec les canadiens et que les
canadiennes veulent un gouvernement à
qui respectent les lois des tic est ce
que la grc devrait rester de côté
pendant l'élection suspendre ses
activités dans quête où l'examen qu'elle
est en train de mener
aujourd'hui j'ai fait un appel pour
justine bruneau de laver le privilège
lorsque les individus dans son bureau
pour témoigner à pour donner leur
évidence aujourd'hui question pensez
vous que le premier ministre dit la
vérité quand il dit qu'il n'avait aucun
lien avec leur renoncement à ce secret
du conseil des ministres réponse non je
pense qu'il a menti aux canadiens le
pouvoir de renoncer à la confidentialité
du cabinet et le pouvoir de lever le
privilège est entre les mains du premier
ministre
il a le pouvoir de faire il devrait agir
aujourd'hui même question vous rendez au
québec
est ce que vous allez parler du projet
de loi 21
réponse j'ai été clair là dessus notre
parti ne pourrait jamais envisagé cela
au niveau fédéral nous allons toujours
défendre les droits des canadiens et la
liberté d'expression religieuse
bonjour monsieur le commissaire à
l'éthique n'a pas vraiment influencer
l'opinion un politique de l'électeur
qu'en pensez vous réponse écoutez ce
n'est pas une question sondage
il faut démontrer au québec monsieur
trudeau a perdu l'autorité morale de
gouverner elle a géré ci prend la chose
assez au sérieux pour commencer à faire
un cadre des individus au bureau du
premier ministre
c'est pourquoi c'est très important
comme ce trio prennent une
responsabilité personnelle est il qu'il
lève le privilège il a le pouvoir de
faire je vais faire une prédiction il va
mentir aujourd'hui là dessus et va
continuer à bâtir tout comme il l'a fait
au tout début il a regardé les canadiens
et en droit dans les yeux et il a dit
que les élections étaient fausses
ensuite il a dit que l'amour c'est le bo
n'a jamais exprimé ses préoccupations
c'était faux il a menti il a dit parce
que c'était l'emploi ou le siège social
de snc lavalin est en jeu on sait
maintenant que cette info début du
scandale
il a été incapable d'honnêteté face au
canadien et tour après tour il s'est
fait prendre la main dans le sac des
mensonges alors son refus de renoncer ou
secrets cela veut dire qu'ils cachent
encore quelque chose de pire s'il
n'avait rien à cacher il devrait le
priver l'agile d'estrella gers et faire
son travail sans entrave
raison pour laquelle a continué de
refuser de les lever les problèmes c'est
parce qu'il ya quelque chose à cacher
plus grave qu'annoncé aujourd'hui alors
encore je lui demande les privilèges dès
maintenant
un joker donc premier point de presse de
cette campagne électorale justin trudeau
dit il a perdu l'autorité morale pour
gouverner il s'accroche à cette nouvelle
du globe and mail ce matin qui montrent
que parce que des mines et se sont liées
au secret ils ne peuvent pas collaborer
pleinement à l'enquêté il ne pourrait
pas collaborer pleinement à l'enquêté de
la grc
donc il met l'accent bien sûr sur ça et
on aura l'occasion de décortiquer mais
d'abord tour de table là dessus les
autres propositions il revient avec son
son leitmotiv qu'il veut me remettre
plus d'argent en est proche des
canadiens dont il veut pas non plus
oublier le le grand angle mais cette
question de confiance est question
d'éthique va être au centre de sa
campagne d'autant plus j'osais que le
globe lui donne des munitions ce matin
oui c'est un beau cadeau vraiment là que
le groupe fait monsieur chien ce matin
on verra si ça va rapporter des
dividendes pour lui mais depuis la
sphère snc lavalin c'est le discours de
monsieur chez eux alors le parti libéral
et surtout justin trudeau serait
corrompu les il le traite de menteur
ouvertement comme c'est assez rare comme
on le croit mais non mais dit il à et
développement si donc il le traite de
menteur il ya pas dit il a induit la
population le langage codé et et donc
c'est de toujours c'est d'essayer de
ramener cette image du parti libéral du
scandale des commandites
monsieur chiffres quand il parle de
scandale il met toujours le mot au
pluriel ou s'il parle de ce qu'est n'ose
pas juste un scandale est ce que je
trouve bizarre dans son discours c'est
que quand il dit et nous l'alternative
alors on penserait qu'il parlerait des
tic qui parlerait de morale il parle de
remettre l'argent dans les poches des
canadiens alors peut-être qu'il va
falloir qu'ils recalibre là parce que
quand stephen harper était allé très
très fortement sur la question de
l'éthique avec avec les libéraux sous
jean chrétien et paul martin le scandale
des commandites
il il avait du matériel à mettre sur la
table pour nous on va être en voie
d'être plus black blanc on va laver plus
blanc que blanc voici comment nous
allons faire la commission comme
j'aurais dû faye avait dit oui oui des
narcos peu d'argent aux six essais je
pense que ceux qui ceux qui se
démarquent cette affaire là c'est que là
il y avait de l'argent public ou
d'argent qui a été peut-être mines dans
les poches des libéraux sa sellerie
sarkozy l'association personnes qui
approuvent et non je sais rester là
scandale des commandes non mais ça s'est
lassé sauf que c'est l'imagination plus
des gens ce scandale si c'est un
scandale une chicane entre des ministres
du cabinet est aussi une enfreinte à la
loi d'une façon que la majorité des
canadiens pensent ne comprennent pas
toutes les nuances l'auteur trance y est
ça qui aurait enfreint c'est pour ça que
c'est plus du site monsieur que de faire
je suis d'accord avec toi josé que de
faire de la matière de going home rist l
argent s'est-elle rien n'est moins gens
comprenaient un comprenez moi même
rapport des rapports avec une femme il
ya trois ans le rapport est clair net
oui le dossier snc lavalin et dont
l'équipe est plus compliqué mais rate on
traite un premier ministre de menteur et
qu'on dit qu'il ya plus l'autorité
morale de gouverner il faut aussi offrir
une alternative sur ce plat la moins
touchée pourquoi j'aurais l'autorité
morale pourquoi moi je ne ferais pas ça
voici ce que moi je ferai vous dit qu'il
n'a pas réussi jusqu'à mais sa réponse
et poissons l'argent dans les poches des
électeurs yat-il encore beaucoup de
millage entre guillemets à faire pour
les conservateurs sur snc lavalin la
réponse courte sinon réponse course et
non sur les tic en général oui parce que
justin trudeau quand même le seul
premier ministre l'histoire avait alors
été reconnu coupable deux fois par le
commissaire à l'éthique d'abord en
finnois sont les conflits d'intérêts ce
comme un voyage braga tiennent le voyage
sur l'île privée et l'ordre comme sarah
l'éthique le sur la sphère snc-lavalin
cet été donc les conservateurs ont beau
jeu de faire une partie de campagne là
dessus ils ont eu par contre une douche
assez froides au mois d'août quand le
rapport du commissaire dit on est arrivé
et que les libéraux ont continué à
monter dans les sondages ce que ça
voulait dire c'est grosso modo les gens
s'étaient fait une tête sur cette
histoire là on blâme justin trudeau où
on trouve qu'il a bien agi pour
l'intérêt québécois pour se protéger
c'est sociale
cela valait mais les tranchées sont
profondes et reste plus beaucoup de gens
qui se promènent entre ces deux opinions
là et donc même un gros qu'un bon gros
rapports assez sévère au port fait
bouger les aiguilles et donc jusqu'à ce
que ça veut dire c'est que ça peut être
un belle toile de fond mais les
conservateurs vont pas gagner cette
campagne électorale sur l'éthique est
intéressant on a parlé un peu plus tôt
de la laïcité dans quelle mesure les
chefs fédéraux vont vouloir se porter à
la défense des gens qui sont contre la
loi 21 au québec
et vous avez vu à la confiance la
question c'est est-ce que vous allez
évoluer puisse défendre les gens qui ne
font hélas il avait pu disparaître ce
jeu est monté dans l'optique où est ce
qu'elle est ouais donc il n'y aura pas
de grandes déclarations car les droits
individuels de la part du chef
conservateur
non c'est très clair on avait dit [ __ ]
tôt ici sur le plateau que c'est pas une
question auxquelles les chefs veulent
toucher monsieur chez eux non plus parce
qu'il veut augmenter ses sièges au
québec et les conservateurs ont une
tradition pas souffler c'est sûr mais
nationaliste envers le québec monsieur
rapport avait reconnu le droit du québec
dans ce premier mandat je pense de
l'autodétermination je me trompe pas
c'est quelque chose qui est car fait
partie de l'adn des conservateurs alors
monsieur va pas je pense se mettre sur
la question des projets de loi 26 avec
joseph vous en avez fait mention il a
parlé de remèdes passerait à savoir
revenir plutôt moyen campagne remet de
l'argent dans les poches des
contribuables ont un mandat gerald
bonjour gérard aujoux on est à gerald de
venir nous donner ses lumières
parce que on va parler de fiscalité puis
d'impôt puis monsieur promet de remettre
de l'argent mais d'abord question
préalable si je peux dire est ce que
l'économie canadienne se porte mieux
aujourd'hui qu'il y a quatre à la
question traditionnelle l'économie
canadienne est en croissance depuis
quatre ans rappelez vous pendant la
campagne électorale en 2015 et une
récession technique c'est-à-dire deux
trimestres négatifs de suite au canada
c'est pas tout le monde qui
reconnaissait la validité de cette façon
de décrire ce qu'est une récession ça
s'est passé donc durant la campagne
électorale jusqu'à quel point ça peut
avoir un effet
ya quatre ans je pense qu'on peut y
penser encore un peu maintenant depuis
quatre ans on est en croissance
économique 2015 a été une année de
faible croissance parce que les prix du
pétrole ont chuté 2016 2017 a été une
bonne année 2010 8,1 ralentissement le
problème au canada c'est que l'alberta
n'arrive pas encore à se relever de la
chute des prix du pétrole de 2015-2016
donc l'alberta est affaibli par sa
j'approche ou est en récession tente de
remonter la pente s'affaiblit l'ensemble
de l'économie canadienne et la
croissance et en ontario et au québec
présentement les emplois la croissance
économique tout est créé au québec et en
ontario en grande partie donc de ce côté
ci si on veut du canada de se boucher du
canada l'économie va bien et
probablement que monsieur trudeau peut
en tirer profit
mais à l'autre bout du pays en alberta
ya une vraie colère et il ya une vraie
tension contenue que le prix du pétrole
demeure assez faible ce qui accentue
cette différence coup plus que l'on voit
de plus en plus dans les intentions de
vote entre contre l'ouest et l'ontario
et le québec d'autre part oui dans ce
pays là en plus nous avons nous manquons
mais devient cinq cent mille postes
aucun da vacants présentement alors ça
ralenti l'économie monsieur trudeau s'en
va dans un sens n'y avait pas le choix
parce qu'il ya une date fixée pour
l'élection un bon moment sur le plan
économique parce qu'une récession est
possible en 2020 2021 on en parle assez
souvent il ya la main d'oeuvre qui
manque qui ralenti l'économie
présentement c'est certain que le
prochain premier ministre que ce soit
monsieur trudeau que ce soit une autre
personne un autre chef qui soit premier
ministre il aura à gérer une contraction
ralentissement de l'économie des
difficultés économiques ce sera dans son
monde
monsieur scheer promet de revenir à
l'équilibré budgétaire il le fait la
chambre de commerce de montréal la
semaine dernière ils avaient faux moi
mais pour la première fois en 4 5 1 et
du ps en prendre un peu plus de temps 5
ha parce qu'il veut surtout pas que l'on
croit qu'il va avoir des compressions
comme en ontario où ailleurs au québec
on a connu ça aussi
ma question est ce que la question du
déficit
c'était vraiment encore une question qui
angoisse les gens qui angoisse les
économistes ou bien qu'avec la taille du
déficit au canada c'est pas majeurs
comme problème je reprends l'expression
d'alec réponse cours non je n'ai lu que
ça angoisse à angoisse une partie de la
population certainement mais je ne pense
pas que ça angoisse la majorité des gens
d'abord monsieur trudeau a été élu sur
un programme de déficit mais sur un
programme où il devait revenir à
l'équilibré budgétaire maintenant
deuxièmement les déficits ne sont pas
importants la dette n'est pas importante
par rapport à l'économie et le canada
l'une des situations financières les
meilleurs sur la peine
une note de crédit de triple à cela dit
ça fait quand même 70 milliards de
déficit en quatre ans supplémentaires
et c'est 20 milliards cette année à un
moment où on craint une récession
et si on dit récession dit dépenses
publiques supplémentaires et plus gros
déficit
donc monsieur scheer en raison dans un
sens d'arrêter dire je vais faire un
déficit zéro la première ou la deuxième
année il aura probablement une situation
économique
si les premiers ministres plus difficile
et du côté de monsieur trudeau il est
très difficile aussi de promettre le
déficit zéro à partir de maintenant il
ne promet même plus le retour au déficit
zéro
la question budgétaire et les complexes
elle n'est pas dramatique mais elle peut
être préoccupante si le gouvernement
perd le contrôle des dépenses et
n'arrivent plus à revenir à liquide
c'est la théorie de monsieur shirt à
chaque wii répète que monsieur trudeau
est trop dépensier sas que c'est porteur
dans le plein est-ce qu'il va chercher
bien sûr qu'il ya déjà qu'ils aiment
entendre ce discours là qui voudrait que
les états soient plus économes et moins
dépensiers est-ce que c'est porteur
je pense jose a mentionné que le gros
bonheur la fin cadeau aujourd'hui alain
de siauliai
ils ont fait un autre cadeau dans un
sens identique c'est la première fois
que les gens utilisent leurs économies
pour rembourser des dettes au lieu de
les investir alors c'est une perte de
richesse personnelle en moyenne à
travers le pays c'est sûr qu'il ya
certaines parties du pays comme
l'alberta qui sauront
plus sur cet accord là mais il ya un
certain malaise parmi les canadiens
envers la dette d'être personnel ou
autre alors messieurs chez eux je pense
essaye de miser sur sur cette question
qui vous dit au revoir pardonnez moi il
s'envole à trois rivières où il va faire
campagne aujourd'hui donc pour montrer
l'importance du québec pour les
conservateurs mais voici le bon exemple
en plus c'est symbolique le premier
endroit qu'on visait trois rivières
circonscriptions où l'ancien maire de
trois-rivières et candidat conservateur
trois rivières les conservateurs l'ont
vraiment dans leur mire comme d'un au
québec
pardonnez moi oui et c'est sa baisse est
pour terminer là dessus je pense qu'il
ya une certaine clientèle toujours au
canada se soucie des questions
économiques et le déficit et devrait
parce que je pense que oui on risque une
récession dans un an ou deux mais je
pense que oui à cause du fait que
monsieur trudeau n'a rien promis sur ça
et a été été gagnant la dernière fois
sans promettre ou en promettant de faire
des déficits je pense qu'elle a angoissé
- parmi la moyenne derrière giral vous
nous parliez du déficit aux côtés du
journal américain avoue dix mille
milliards les gens regardent top 10 mais
nous la petite bière sso faudra mener
par rapport au pib a mis bien l'économie
exactement donc aux états unis on est à
3 4 5% du pib quand on parle du déficit
au canada ou en mode 1% du produit
intérieur comme je vous dis c'est pas
très important par rapport à l'économie
mais compte tenu que généralement en
économie quand il y à de la croissance
économique
vous êtes capable de revenir à
l'équilibré budgétaire les déficits ou
fait ça quand ça va pas bien pour
stimuler l'économie fait pas ça quand ça
va bien ça va relativement bien dans
l'économie depuis quatre ans et les
déficits n'ont pas baissé les familles
monsieur trudeau adipi d'ailleurs ils
reprochent d'en proposer aux médias
quand ils reprochent à a déjà qu'on ne
parle pas assez de ça c'est à dire qu'il
a réussi à faire reculer la pauvreté
chez les enfants ce que c'est
significatif
est-ce que les retours les transferts de
tahoua ont changé la vie de gens au
canada
probablement que puis beaucoup d'experts
la firme
le point le plus important de ce mandat
c'est la location canadienne pour
enfants qui a été véritablement bonifié
cas vraiment changer les choses pour
beaucoup de familles c'est un c'est une
remise fiscale
on est venu bonifier ce qui existait
déjà nous transformer ce qui existait
déjà et même qu en cours de mandat on a
décidé de l'indexer à l'inflation pour
s'assurer que la bonification grandi
stock la location canadienne pour
enfants est un retour important pour les
familles aient eu la baisse d'impôts
également au début du mandat et la
hausse d'impôts sur les revenus sur les
revenus un peu plus un peu plus élevé
mais la baisse d'impôts donc sur le plan
fiscal les un travail qui a été fait est
ce qu'on peut aller plus loin
peut-être je ne sais pas mais qui sait
un bilan présenté qui dit baisse
d'impôts dit déficit supplémentaire
parce que c'est moins de revenus pour
l'état
ça c'est deux choses en effet et je
pense qu'il faut s'attendre à ce que
justin trudeau pendant la campagne fera
la démonstration que au delà d'un
endettement peut-être personnel tu as tu
as tout à fait raison il ya beaucoup de
canadiens qui sont et qui est
personnellement mes kilos contribué
quand même améliorer le sort de la
fameuse classe moyenne celle à qui on
s'adresse tous les partis vont
s'adresser à la classe moyenne est
nouveau on se souvient qu'en 2015 justin
trudeau c'était à la classe moyenne et
ceux qui travaillent très fort pour pour
la rejoindre
oui ça mais en même temps sur la
question du déficit en 2015
justin trudeau sur le plan idéologique
au fait faire un virage majeur à la
population qui était conditionné depuis
vais t'en par pline politiciens plein
analystes que le déficit c'était le
diable en personne
ayoub et religieux rick dogme un dogme
et que et que l'équilibré budgétaire
c'est assez gras l'on pouvait pour vivre
comme pays et que pays est géré comme
une famille avait plaidé mme ri comme ça
qui aurait plié
oui vous avez beaucoup monsieur parizeau
oh oui oui qui lui parlait justement de
dogmes religieux bon et l'ajuster to do
a réussi à renverser sa et le québec
subit l'austérité est aussi sous
monsieur guillard a beaucoup souffert de
ça et ça je pense que ça a marqué les
perceptions populaire que c'est correct
les déficits quand c'est nécessaire
c'est contrôlé au delà de l'aide du
spectacle le plus est est peut-être
l'aspect plus abstrait pour la plupart
des gens mais c'est que ce n'est plus un
péché mortel et c'est vraiment ce que
vous dites est très important parce que
la dernière la dernière fois sa vraie
place et monsieur mike est dans une
drôle de situation qui lui alors le
terrain du club
[ __ ] étaient plus austère entre guillemets
les libéraux qui dit arrêtez de vous en
faire
on a les moyens de dépenser on va
s'occuper des familles de la classe
moyenne
c'est un paris qu'ils avaient faits
qu'ils ont remporté la dernière fois
bien sûr mon coeur a raté et on voit
monsieur chirp on parle de théologie on
voit monsieur s'éloigne de ce dogme du
déficit est la radio la marge de
manoeuvre donc saisir compris où on a
saisi que à 10 15 20 milliards de
déficit on est quand même autour du zéro
on n'est pas très loin du déficit zéro
puis on va pas virer fou avec ça parce
qu'on est en bonne juin pour cent par
rapport au pib s'assemble la différence
entre un comme diète et coke zero là
c'est
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est une très très bonne
discussion qu'on a eue sur le sur
l'économie sur les enjeux économiques de
cette campagne gerald merci on faisait
commerce est sûre ce soir 18h30 au 17h
ou 18h à 21h ou 22h vous êtes partout
mais c'est important
le contexte dans quel contexte on vit
puis les chefs donc auront à se
positionner là dessus
merci gerald bonne journée je vous
rappelle mesdames et messieurs qu'il est
quoi très bientôt 10 heures dans trois
minutes on attend monsieur trudeau à
rideau hall donc vous voyez l'image
il va venir d'abord il va aller faire
une petite visite de courtoisie à la
gouverneure générale
payet ils vont peut-être pas noté un
café vous allez lire ça demain qu'il ya
des gens qui aiment vous donner les
détails un petit four et là ils vont
parler un peu des politesses et la
gouverneure générale va donc accepté sa
demande de dissoudre le parlement
fédéral et l'élection madeleine va
commencer la campagne électorale devrait
agir va commencer tout de suite une fois
qu'il sera sorti bien que c'est déjà
commencé mais se fier j'avais vu et
parce que les traditions ça se modifie
pour lui vu d'habitude on attendait que
le premier ministre chef façon point de
presse avant de faire les autres points
après monsieur cheikh pour des questions
de logistique a décidé de parler avant
donc on viens de l'entendre alors
madeleine mais ce trou d'eau qui va
s'adresser aux médias je sais pas est-ce
qu'on va prendre quelques questions à
des petites ces deux trois français de
trois en anglais mais il y aura des
questions je crois j'espère oui on cet
angle on s'attend des questions à poser
à justin trudeau
donc il va demander la dissolution du
parlement
on va se lancer dans une campagne qui
est relativement courte
si on la compare à celle de 2015 qui
avait duré je vous rappelle 78 jours là
on est toujours un de cette campagne qui
on va endurer 40
donc c'est relativement court justin
trudeau doit défendre son bilan mais pas
seulement défendre son bilan
tout à l'heure on parlait de toute la
question du déficit et j'imagine que les
libéraux vont vouloir encore frappé
l'imaginaire avec leurs promesses
on ne sait pas encore ce qu'ils vont
proposer pour essayer
et de courtiser l'électorat canadien
dans certains comtés aussi très précis
qu'il vise pour se maintenir au pouvoir
et il le souhaite obtenir un autre
mandat
le deuxième pour justin trudeau s'il
part liée à le faire vous parlez d'un
douchy évidemment il a tenu un point de
presse parce qu'il voulait parler de la
sphère snc-lavalin ce matin c'était pas
prévu au départ mais quand il a vu la
une du global est l'illustrateur
retraite ont obligé leurs charges et les
plats des tons obligé j'entends des
choses et leveaux tout à leurs 10
rebonds et ils se reportent tout de
suite à son plan de campagne à la
question d'avoir plus d'argent dans vos
poches vous souvenir que l'hiver dernier
un duo scheer avait beaucoup critiqué le
gouvernement
mais c'était du même coup campé dans son
rôle d'opposition en faisant ça on ne
l'avait pas vous beaucoup vu comme un
futur éventuel premier ministre et les
stratèges conservateurs l'ont reconnu
que si finalement c'était un couteau à
deux tranchants qu'ils devaient proposer
des choses aux canadiennes montré qu'il
était un premier ministre en attente et
moi j'ai vu le prendre le point de
presse d'indochine avec cette lorgnette
là comme s'il voulait vous rappeler aux
canadiens bush critiquent à saintes il
avalait mais souvenez-vous mon plan de
campagne je veux leur donner
n'oubliez pas que je vais lâcher au
langage que vous allez comprendre puis
j'ai des choses concrètes de oui
exactement
alors c'était un peu la façon dont j'ai
vu le point de presse de richir tout à
l'heure et j'imagine que justin trudeau
sera questionné sur la question de snc
lavalin ont la vie ça n'avait pas
beaucoup fait bouger l'aiguillé lorsque
le commissaire à l'éthique avait rendu
public son rapport au mois d'août mais
c'était au mois d'août et il y avait
peut-être moins de monde qui écoute et
on sait que pendant les campagnes
électorales les citoyens son avantage à
l'ecoute donc on va voir comment ça va
se passer
il est campagne électorale vous l'avez
dit plutôt madeleine on le tout souligné
ce effet de surprise et heureusement ce
n'est pas comme du papier à musique qui
a le plein d'un côté il ya la réalité de
l'autre alors par exemple on vient
d'avoir une note monsieur chien s'envole
vers trois rivières est il par an dans
quelques secondes donc d'ottawa mais son
avion peut-être devra atterrir à québec
parce qu'il ya une condition il ya des
conditions météo qui ça brasse à
trois-rivières apparemment alors voilà
il faut s'ajuster
chaque jour on doit s'ajuster à ce que
le l'adversaire dit undi port alors on
rappelle d'ici quelques secondes on
verra les premiers mots ça serait
intéressant de voir ce que monsieur
trudeau va va prendre le taureau par les
cornes et va parler de santé laval un
pivot tenter de fermer le débat mais
aussi de se justifier en danger fait ça
pour telle ou telle raison
merci bonsoir où il voudra passer sous
silence les journalistes le vont lui
rappeler il avait déjà commencé à être
un peu plus offensif en un an nous
lorsque notre parole du commissaire à
l'éthique avait été déposée il était
déjà un petit peu moins sur la défensive
des rappeler les emplois pour qu'on
l'avait fait puis qu'ils divergeaient
d'opinion avec les commissaires à
l'éthique sur la manière dont ça s'était
passé
moi je m'attends à ce qu'ils répètent
toujours les deux ou trois mêmes phrases
pour le prochain mois autour de sennecé
lavalin est ce que ça s'est bien passé
comme on l'aurait souhaité non on aurait
pu faire autrement oui est ce qu'on le
fait pour les bonnes raisons
oui ça va être grosso modo ça dans
toutes sortes de phrases mais résumer
pas mal autour de cette ne justifierait
pas de pension j'emploie plus les bras
canadien de le croire ou non mais ça va
être la ligne qu'il va tenir pendant les
15 prochaines jouer si je ne serai
jamais gêné de me battre pour les
emplois des canadiens
et comme le disait alec tout à l'heure
dans la mesure où la sphère snc lavalin
ont polarisé l'opinion publique un sont
déjà pas mal défini que plus vraiment
d'opinion flottante
ben c'est sûr qu'il va continuer il faut
qu'il continue sur cette ligne là il
faut qu'ils insistent beaucoup sur les
emplois et des emplois canadiens pour
juste québécoise vous êtes les pertes il
est déjà il a connu les pertes face à ce
dossier là point c'est réglé l'info qui
ce qui met sur les gens qui sont plutôt
d'accord avec l'attitude qu'il avait
salam holtom batailleur aussi parce
qu'on avait peut-être perdu un peu je
pense que cette question de moralité que
monsieur chez eux soulève
le danger cela cesse a provoqué les
libéraux de sortir tous les vidéos
pouvaient trouver et indochine où il a
dit des choses qui peut être soit
contredisent ce qu'il dit aujourd'hui un
peu ou qui est vraiment je pense sorte
un côté qu' il y perd pas ce ne serait
pas attirants pour les électeurs alors
ce qu'on voit c'est que essentiellement
il ya une campagne moral contre 1,2
scheer en demandant que monsieur trudeau
soit le chef moral en lui pointant le
doigt dedans snc-lavalin démontre qu'on
peut pas avoir confiance en vous les
libéraux font cette campagne chaque
semaine en sortant un autre vidéo et
c'est pas monsieur trudeau qui les soft
skills et les députés par exemple qui a
sorti un sur l'éducation et eux ils font
la bataille mais ce trou d'eau est ici
eux ils font la bataille salle ici
contre messieurs et le fait d'être hacké
un peu de son message est la question
que les gens peut être se sont opposés
dans le groupe du scandale des sentiers
lavalin en tout cas de cette histoire
devrait agir de sennecey lavalin c est
ce que monsieur tu nous avais le ressort
nécessaire ce que c'était est-ce que ses
qualités de leader avait disparu si tant
est qu'ils en avaient a lancé ça que les
gens ont du pittoresque lui il peut
faire face à l'adversité
inutile donné le là donné le ton et
aller se battre
c'est ça le doute s'est installé alors
ce sont des filles et je suis persuadé
que ce qui lui a fait perdre des plumes
dans les sondages s'était pas la sphère
snc-lavalin comme tel mais son manque de
leadership il est il était
continuellement côté de ses pompes
on va on s'en souvient on ne croyait
même pas ce qu'on voyait à quel point il
est hésitant change de version
continuellement mais là en effet il a
repris du tonus
il l'a trouvé
sa ligne sur snc lavalin et c'était très
important ça parce que quand on sait
quand on est premier ministre qu'on veut
deuxième mandat la question du question
et c'est ça la raison c'est et c'était
impression que changer les histoires
tous les jours ils savaient pas quel
message envoyé 15 c'était la vérité ou
non mais c'était la compétence surdoué
je pense que pour les conservateurs ce
serait plus d'insister là-dessus
peut-être qui serait intéressant pour
eux dans cette campagne que sur le
détail de survie des gens ne comprennent
pas malheureusement tous libres alors
voilà mesdames et messieurs monsieur
trudeau et et son épouse qui avance
bancs des classes à l'est pas il vous
est sûre il renie son veston ils se sont
changés oui s échanger ouais alors
sophie grégoire et justin trudeau on va
écouter s'il parle en passe
on en parle d'ailleurs d'un crochet à la
roulotte alors on le disait plus tous
ceux qui n'étaient pas avec nous ce free
gloire va faire campagne avec son avec
justin trudeau remet aussi séparément au
québec beaucoup on va la voir elle va
faire une tournée canadienne également
ont misé sur cette image dont 7 sur
cette idée d'unité et de et on sait que
ce fut guérie guara une à une audience
sophie grégoire il ya beaucoup de femmes
entre autres les deux gens qu'il aime
beaucoup
alors on va c'est sa campagne électorale
tous les atouts - être joué je pense
pour jouer aussi sur l'image féministes
du premier ministre on a touché à sophie
grégoire c'est vrai il milite pour les
femmes pour les jeunes filles fait du
travail de niveau là dans ce coin là
donc c'est très légitime qu'elles se
présentent dans cette optique ce qui
pourrait aider son premier disque
souffert un peu sur le côté pro
féministe à cause des scènes sénat
balaie un oui quoique de façon générale
on peut pas dire que monsieur turdu
n'est pas sensible à la cause des femmes
d'une minorité de femmes dans son
cabinet d'une façon que certains pas
c'était très 10 respectueux oui mais ont
aussi aussi que l'électorat féminin est
plus libérale que conservateurs et les
déclarations de monsieur scheer sur
l'avortement n'auriez fait pour l'aider
lui non plus alors si pour ceux qui la
présence de sophie grégoire consolidé
peut-être même augmenté mais pas la part
des lecteurs au féminin et alec je
serais pas étonné si vous parler
d'avortement josé que monsieur tout doux
même en fasse mention là dans une tirade
l'an 10 ans il voulait pas revenir en
arrière
robes des vieux débat qui pourrait être
ouvert en faisant référence à
l'avortement et voudrait vont jouer les
soucis mais vous savez on est rendu à
quatre vidéos le dal passé d'indochine
que les libéraux ont déterré dont un
show faisait allusion faite à l'heure où
ces dix ministres du gouvernement
trudeau qui ont mis ce public sur leur
twitter sur facebook etc
l'objectif c'est pas autant parlé de
mariage gay d'avortement de compression
possible d'éducation tout sauvage ou un
public mais c'est quand on met tous
ensemble que les libéraux essaie de
faire c'est à dire voyez le bon vieux
succès souvenirs ne veut pas faire
confiance aux conservateurs parce qu'ils
ont un agenda caché dit vous est ce pas
en réalité ce qu'ils vont vraiment faire
fortement sur les compressions sur
l'éducation cse la trame narrative qu'on
va essayer de construire ça très bien
marché à l'époque de stephen harper
lorsque paul martin a réussi à
s'accrocher au pouvoir à l'époque il ya
toujours cette petite de cloche chez
l'électorat progressiste que les
conservateurs on peut pas leur faire
confiance et donc on multiplie le type
de vidéos dans le passé d'un de vos
chiens en espérant je le dis on le redit
de coaliser le vote progressiste au tour
de justin trudeau de barrer la route aux
conservateurs
on va l'essayer on va l'essayer et on va
l'essayer en espérant que ça fonctionne
et comment un douche sûrs et est équipé
pour faire face à ça mais justement il
est pas très bien équipés de seaux parce
que les haies mais aussi parce que ses
positions sont six lits de conservatisme
social beaucoup plus appuyée que ce que
stephen rapp earl était bon alors ça
c'est un handicap aussi c'est peut-être
une force dans ses passes électorale
mais c'est une handicap pour essayer
d'élargir la tante conservatrice
évidemment donc dans la mesure où il est
pas capable de dire clairement contraire
mais monsieur truc dont je suis pour le
droit des femmes
au libre-choix l'appartement etc etc ça
va rester un handicap et ça a beau être
des vieux discours qui ont été déterrés
d'après ce qu'on entend sa position a
pas tranchant j'écris c'est ça va dans
les slogans aussi des deux parties c'est
très clair en anglais autre chose fort
worth graphismes avancés c'est
absolument ça veut dire pas reculer
parce qu'au bac world back en anglais
c'est un mot très très très important
dans la langue parce que ça implique
aussi un sens que tu exactement l'ancien
temps où les allées femme était dans la
cuisine en finisse on veut pas reculer
mais en anglais backward ce bout là
c'est sa raison de très forts alors je
sais pas un accent que les libéraux ont
choisi ce slogan là pour les
conservateurs l'aslog le dit c'est plus
pour vous maintenant ça veut dire qu' on
essaie de changer le discours et dire
que c'est l'économie vraiment c'est ce
qui ce qui est plus important mais c'est
chiant parce que monsieur dans un
certain sens il ya une partie de son
intérêt qui aimerait retourner un peu en
arrière et dans certains choix aussi je
pense pas qu'il a tort de dire c'est le
progressisme et à tout prix c'est pas
nécessairement la façon de gouverner de
simplement aller toujours de l'avant il
faut aussi regarder dans la tradition
c'est une vision progressiste
conservatrice ou conservatrices très
importante mais vous le dit bien tasha
il ya une partie de son électorat et de
ses candidats de ce député qui voudrait
d'une certaine façon revenir en arrière
donc ib oise les sensations doit
composer avec les deux oui les deux
tendances oui c'est pas sincèrement si
ce n'est que les questions sociales au
sur les questions sociales c'est une
vision de la société où la famille était
très importante par exemple où on avait
un sens que l'on pouvait se procurer un
logement
toute la question des classes moyennes
cette vision un peu utopique peut-être
des années 50 ou même des années auprès
des des années plus récentes où c'était
plus facile à toronto où il n'y est pas
là le coût moyen d'une maison c'est plus
d'un million de dollars alors la classe
moyenne dans la
9 05 et ne peuvent pas avoir une maison
c'est une vision qui disparaît alors
cette vision de l'entente on pourrait
avoir cette cette ville cette belle vie
c'est quelque chose d'important auquel
les gens s'accrochent mais c'est pas
pour rien que les conservateurs font
campagne là dessus je les lions pas
sortir de leur chapeau aux lions et ont
regardé les sondages on fait des groupes
de discussion et l'économie va bien j'ai
en parlé à des emplois sont disponibles
mais la progression des salaires n'est
pas aussi marc lynn grosse partie de la
classe moyenne nos poches
une grosse partie de la classe moyenne
stein des difficultés ce prix des
maisons à vancouver à toronto à calgary
c'est extrêmement cher et donc si on est
capable de jouer sur l'inquiétude et
individuelle des genres l'objet regarde
le budget à ottawa du vin et 20 30 40
milliards de déficit bref ça m'importe
peu
mais moi ce que je suis capable de me
payer une hypothèque d'avoir d'accéder à
la propriété et d'élever mes enfants à
montréal le coût de la vie augmente
aussi le prix des maisons ont bondi de
manière assez importante
c'est moins marquées qu'ailleurs non le
sens tu peux aussi est-ce qu'il est trop
tôt est ce que ce que steve à ce que
andrew scheer que vu ces marqueurs le
apparaître une campagne un peu trop
rapide alors que dans le fond c'est la
prochaine récession qui va vraiment
faire libérer en faut surtout une autre
chose mais chez les conservateurs on se
dit ce n'est pas de ramener sain
individuellement chacun parce que le
grand tableau va bien qu'ils sont
incapables y ramener individuellement
chacun on l'a peut-être des chances et
mais sur le porteur de ballon sur chiers
lui même dans les cercles conservateurs
est ce qu'on se dit il et il voit ce que
s'améliorer
les gens vont le découvrir tant dans la
campagne est ce qu ont misé là dessus je
pense que et je pense que il va miser
sur les débats certainement pour
peut-être ce dimanche doit se démarquer
doit se montrer je change arrive quelque
chose oui il doit y voit démontré plus
de charisme qu'il a et qu'il a démontré
à date je pense que il se positionne
comme un chef un chef fort et doit
donner cette impression alors c'est
important pour lui
je pense vraiment de se positionner
ainsi je sais pas exactement comment il
va choisir ses moments mais je pense que
les débats
ça va être aidé occasion pour lui de
temps pointé le doigt monsieur trudeau 2
oui je passe de marquer ses faiblesses
de lui rappeler ses faiblesses messieurs
chute en débat il était le speaker de la
chambre des communes pendant très très
longtemps alors on n'a pas vraiment une
image de lui comme des batteurs mais on
va voir nom de cette petite parenthèse
que joue plus que vous parlez des débats
le set li lé moment inscrit à votre
calendrier 7 octobre débat en anglais le
10 octobre débat en france est donc
organisée par la commission pérol et des
bas des face à face de tva également
pour le marché québécois et c'est tout
le monsieur tous les bretons et mais
c'est rue de la merci des banques
je combats pas pour monsieur trudeau n'y
va pas parce qu'il a très bien fait la
dernière fois à ces débats les à toronto
mais en tout cas est aussi des basses
mettra une commission ghanéen - d'abord
puis à un moment un peu plus solennelle
il bon oui mais mais si on revient
monsieur gilles c'est intéressant parce
qu'il a quand même la personnalité qui
l'a donc oui il se présente comme le
premier ministre en attente donc où
c'est vrai en effet il doit donner une
image de leader fort mais en même temps
la population c'est peut-être plus haut
qu'à cherchent non plus on est à une ère
plus moderne on peut déjà un peu plus et
moitié c'est justin trudeau a très bien
fonctionné dans ce dans ce créneau là
mais si on peut pas leur faire alors il
devra ensuite je me souviens des débats
à propos de mr puis je me suis même d'un
été indien
il faut qu'il s'en débarrasse il ne sera
jamais premier mineur ils n'ont pas la
personnalité et froid comme un glaçon
mais qui tenait la médiation fier cela
et puis on exactement
or il ya façon et oui alors il doit
cesse mais ça son handicap au québec
mais c'est cher c'est son français alors
oui parle français mais il est peu à
l'aise en français et cherche souvent
ces mots c'est un peu comme disait
gaston miron cdu traduit du l' on voit
qu'il ya de la difficulté et ça ça peut
ça peut être très difficile dans les
débats parce qu'il va être avec des gens
comme ça qui s'exprime bien en français
et ça on le vue il est beaucoup plus
esthétique et plus nerveux
s'il veut s'il veut faire s'il veut
faire des gains au québec
je ne sais pas s'il va avoir le temps
d'avoir un tuteur ne savions qu'ils
retravaillent plus encore les cheveux
cabinet en français il dit qu'il va il
promet de pouvoir donner un discours
d'ici la fin de la campagne sans notes
on verra vous savez plus où moins
inspirant il est moins connu de la
population moi j'ai passé plusieurs
jours avec lui pour un grand portrait
que j'ai fait et puis c'est vrai que
c'est quelqu'un qui ressemble beaucoup
estimaient dans l'après en termes de
personnalité plus où rien n'est vraiment
mais quelqu'un qui est pas
nécessairement à l'aise en public
quelqu'un qui va pas spontanément vers
les électeurs tout le contraire de
justin trudeau donc l'image est très
importante en campagne électorale donc
tout à l'heure louis blues ont menacé de
le montrer avec des gens en interaction
avec des gens parce que c'est quelqu'un
qui est à la base assez réservé est
quelqu'un d'assez timide froid alors
est-ce qu'on serait capable de le monter
mon expression des coûts ainsi pendant
la campagne électorale
faudra voir aussi difficile de se
réinventer en 40 jours
en même temps je peux pas m'empêcher de
penser que le plus gros problème d'un
douchez si jack médecins s'étant que le
npd est aussi faible dans les intentions
de vote vous pourriez mettre quelqu'un
le qu'ils soient est patent chez les
conservateurs
le vote nous démocrates étant écrasé ça
donne une chance à justin trudeau de
pouvoir gouverner c'est un trampoline
pour justin trudeau oser des vases
communicants ses électeurs entre les
pôles hiver reste à voir là aussi où on
a des images yves françois blanchet le
chef du bloc québécois qui va part en
tournée dimanche meilleur des activités
aujourd'hui on veut l'entendre
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
vers 11 heures on nous dit à 11h45 donc
il y aura un point de presse du chef du
bloc
un petit mot peut-être pendant qu'on le
voit on l'a beaucoup souligné quelques
semaines ça va mieux au bloc là
évidemment j'entendais julie
marchessault tout à l'heure nous dire on
espère tripler l'offre open faut rester
réaliste dans les attentats non plus qui
joue avec de trop grosses attentes parce
que le 21 octobre
on va se souvenir de sa josy et ça c'est
un peu la faiblesse de monsieur blanchet
will you feel your ils ont reconstruit
un peu le bloc si on peut dire il ya mis
fin aux débats internes et tout ça mais
faut qu'ils se méfient de lui même un
peu parce que c'est un passionné c'est
un sanguin et des fois l'essor des
choses et face à jack meeting aussi il
faut faire très attention la question
des signes religieux tout ça il ya une
limite là qu'il faut pas qu'il faut pas
atteindre
moi ce qui me frappe le plus c'est que
le bloc a changé changer de locomotive
1 alors comme la locomotive péquiste
voit très mal on a vu que monsieur
monsieur blanchet ont recentré sur les
intérêts du québec plus nationaliste il
s'accroche à la locomotive de la cac
finalement il vraiment là il s'inscrit
dans toutes les eaux magnifiques des
lèvres que les fédéralistes pour nous on
va représenter le bug qui se perd mais
c'est quand même quelque chose qu'un
parti qui était fonds au dépourvu
jusqu'à l'indépendance du québec c'est
est ce que monsieur jarre disait la
maintenance s'accroche
après un parti qui n'est pas souvent
nice mais pas du tout monsieur legault
était très très très même si c'est un
explique keith l'humain il était très
très clair donc si vraiment tient
complètement largué la locomotive
péquiste qui prend la locomotive kaki il
est vrai la jirs lesur et ça peut être
payant
c'est peut être payeur parce que c'est
ce qui est populaire dans les lecteurs
francophones ans et en même temps il ya
bien dans telles qui dit
le problème c'est pas là où le fédéral
on va faire la séparation un peu pour
élever deux mais je pense qu'il ya un
très grand défi de ne pas avoir trop
d'attentes pour ne pas dire des sottises
non plus parce qu'elle a une chance
maintenant vraiment de faire une percée
est elle aussi est connu un peu pour
faire des déclarations d'impôts et
l'inouï voyait les images des
journalistes qui se prépare à poser des
questions à justin trudeau dès qu'il
sort on ira bien sûr en direct il est en
discussion avec la gouverneure générale
ils demandent la dissolution de la
chambre des communes est ce qui peut
jouer pour le bloc ci si jamais parce
que les journalistes ne lâcheront pas
ils vont demander à monsieur trudeau
monsieur chez un monsieur singh est ce
que vous allez défendre uction contre la
loi sur la liste ici les trois autres
partis sont forcés à entrer dans cette
ronde là monsieur blanchet pourra dire
moi je suis le seul qui appuient cette
vision des choses sont vertes bac qui
est appuyée on le sait par gramme
majorité de québécois est l'outil qu'un
monsieur blanc chips on peut peut-être
voir sanaa ont peut-être mort sanaa les
débats c'est que bon ok maintenant vous
vous en mêlez paul vous voulez pas
vraiment contesté mais monsieur trudeau
si vous restez au pouvoir monsieur chien
si vous démenez premier ministre qu'est
ce que vous allez faire ou la main
l'élection face à la loi mais tu es
allez-vous vous joindre aux
contestations judiciaires
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
maintenant c'est maintenant mais après
l'élection ça va être quoi oui alec moi
je pense que l'électorat qui est motivée
par un vote très identitaire comme toi
loi 21 et déjà au bloc québécois
mon impression c'est que si c'était un
argument aussi valable en campagne
électorale pauline marois était au
pouvoir et au pouvoir plus que 18 mois
alors je suis pas certain qu'on peut
faire énormément de bien avec ce type de
campagne électorale je pense que les
gens aiment débattre de ce sujet là
c'est très émotif qui arrive au moment
de voter ils ne votent pas en fonction
de cette situation
whissell a déconnecté deux hits en
question de l'ingérence fédérale dans le
domaine provincial service accueille
tout le monde au fédéral mais son
chapeau on va pas ingéré alors ça
devient la question si oui on a géré la
il ya des québécois qui sont peut-être
pas souverainiste mais qui sont assises
nationales et la la séparation des
pouvoirs entre les provinces et le
fédéral et on va les voir et si vous le
permettez
oui à london on va se rendre c'est des
images de l'onu dans un interview
christian noël est avec jack meeting
bonsoir crise et bonjour les siens
alors oui depuis le début monsieur singh
doit être découragés si nous écoute
parce que vraiment la tâche paraît
presque insurmontable pour le chef du
npd mais là lui l'ontario il doit
protéger au moins c'est ça qui la bat et
peut-être espérer de faire quelques
gains en ontario c'est ce qu'il espère
faire et si une glissade dans les
sondages si le npd semble en difficulté
au niveau national faudrait le dire aux
partisans qui sont ici présentement au
lancement officiel de monsieur signe
parce que on sent un optimisme on sent
une effervescence ici présentement
oui le déclenchement des élections ça
aide à faire monter les bulles mais les
gens ici sont vraiment convaincus que
leur députée sortante qui ne se
représente pas mais c'est sa fille qui
sera présente à sa place les et matheson
pourra conserver la ville de london la
circonscription ici où on se trouve
et est ce pas aussi faire des gains en
ontario monsieur singh est ici à
l'hampden une ville ouvrière parce qu'il
veut lancer sa campagne sur le thème des
inégalités de la lieu pour les pauvres
contre les plus riches c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que plus tôt cette semaine
ils ont annoncé l'imposition d'une taxe
pour les super riches
les gens qui ont 20 millions de dollars
et plus en avoir
mais monsieur singh se retrouve un peu
pris de court par les révélations ce
matin récensés lavalin qui lui donne des
munitions
d'ailleurs reçu singh a envoyé
un tweed un peu plus tôt ce matin pour
dénoncer ce qui se passe il lance un
appel à la vérité ni plus ni moins en
disant que le premier ministre justin
trudeau devrait ni plus ni moins se
ranger du côté des gens et non du côté
de ses amis et ils demandent que les
gens qui ont des choses à faire des
choses à dire concernant l' enquête de
la grc sur la possible obstruction à la
justice dans l'histoire decency lavalin
me suit rudeau devrait les laisser
parler devrait demander au conseil privé
de donner la directive de lever la
confidentialité ministériel pour que
l'on peut l enquête puisse aller de
l'avant
donc cette histoire snc-lavalin ce matin
ce n'était pas dans les plans de soutien
qui veut parler des inégalités mais ça
lui donne des munitions pour s'attaquer
au problème de vérité et de transparence
et aussi par la bande des questions
d'inégalité
merci merci beaucoup christian alors oui
bien sûr qu'ils feront campagne avec
toute l'énergie dont ils sont capables
c'est la démocratie
puis on le souhaite comme ça mais disons
que les astres sont sont moins en ligne
et joliment pour le npd
disons cela comme ça un petit tour à
vancouver lance martin on s'est parlé un
peu plus tôt
bon les verts vont utiliser tous les
tous les symboles et toutes les images
nécessaires pour vraiment impressionner
les gens vous avez un orque devant vous
un derrière vous oui oui au nord qu
géante gonflable pour montrer tout ce
qu'ils ont le parti a mené cei à
quelques minutes regardez c'est
intéressant parce que dans tout ce
déballage sur l'expansion du pin très
intime antenne en fait les
environnementalistes craignent que s'il
ya plus de transport sur le long de la
côte pacifique plus de transport de
pétroliers avec la population des polars
en fait soit en danger la population qui
vit le long de la côte donc c'est un
beau petit clin d'oeil ce matin du parti
vert et patrice est très important et en
colombie-britannique l'enjeu ici ça va
évidemment l'environnement
les libéraux la dernière fois avait
emporté 40% des sièges devant le npd
devant les conservateurs devant les
verts aussi mais là on le sait tous sens
ils ont acheté un pin pour quatre
milliards et demi dollar alors est-ce
que les britanno colombiens vouloir
voter pour les libéraux ou est ce qu'ils
vont se tourner vers le mpb vers les
verts surveillez aussi la performance
des conservateurs en
colombie-britannique parce que dans les
buts 3 4 et pourrait souffler s'arrête
un jour
merci et on rappelle que madame mais
comme les autres chefs va faire un point
de presse donc merci beaucoup
il est plutôt là bas tout à l'heure ne
parle à le rendre dès 6 heures du matin
puis damas y avait pas un chat
et c'est normal le canada et les femmes
est un grand pays donc monsieur trudeau
je vous le rappelle est avec la gaule en
général depuis maintenant quoi une
dizaine douzaine de minutes
il devrait faire son arrivée vous allez
le voir et il va faire un discours il y
aura ensuite période de questions ça
donne le temps rappelez-vous pour une
ceux qui suivent les campagnes
électorales à marwa première journée de
campagne au québec
elle avait déclenché un peu plus tôt et
on dit bon mais les discours les gens
écoutent personne alors ça va donner le
ton et il n'y avait pas fait point de
presse et elle l'avait elle avait traîné
sol et trois premiers jours de campagne
c'est important de faire un bon départ
pour tous les chefs là
absolument parce que les gens portent
beaucoup attention à la première semaine
est la dernière semaine la campagne
nous on aime une semaine et toute une
campagne électorale au complet mais les
gens sont pas attentifs pendant 40 jours
première semaine dernières semaines
autour des débats des chefs
évidemment c'est très pointu là pour
vous mais sinon il ya comme un milieu un
peu mou où il peut se passer énormément
de choses mais où les gens sont un peu
moins attentifs particulièrement pour
une campagne électorale fédérale
c'est un peu moins près des gens ont
parfois de santé d'éducation d'euros de
taxe et assurance médicaments qui s
asseoir ce soit un sujet intéressant un
peu moins au québec parce qu'on a déjà
un programme d'assurance médicaments ça
va être surtout technique est ce qu'on
peut avoir une chance à sion c'est ça le
prix des médicaments beaucoup augmenté
dans les dernières années une
préoccupation des gens cela fait partie
effectivement des débats qui va y avoir
mais c'est très concret c'est réel oui
bon début les chefs doivent avoir un bon
début oui et l'important c'est de
d'encadrer la conversation c'est à dire
définir là c'est ce qui va avec la
question posée zélateurs alors on veut
que son message passe par dessus les
autres
est-ce que ça va être l'environnement au
premier plan est ce que ça va l'économie
au premier plan comment est-ce que mais
surtout doit aussi va anticiper les
attaques de ses adversaires et les
réponses avant qu'ils ont la chance de
poser leurs questions
c'est très complet alors ce discours là
c'est vrai c'est important c'est le
premier pas le dernier qu'on va entendre
mais c'est très important
oui il dit
ça évidemment pas décliner ses
politiques ce matin mais il doit
communiquer au canadien son désir de les
amener plus loin à de continuer à
améliorer leurs camions oui mais voilà
alors qui je suis moi j'essaie trudeau
et dans les prochains quatre ans si vous
me donnez un deuxième mandat voici où
j'aimerais vous amener tous ensemble et
pendant la campagne
ben là on verra comment mais c'est c'est
très important parce que demander un
deuxième mandat si presque amour
redemander quelqu'un en mariage cipulis
ccc plus les papillons du début qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire pour vous mais il
faut faire non ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il faut faire plus d'efforts pour
séduire sans tomber dans les travers
qu'on lui a reprochées je pense que le
voyage en inde s'était paroxysme une
certain style je pense qu'ils ont bien
compris sur une libéraux et monsieur
toure douleur compris qu'elle ne pouvait
pas aller dans la caricature comme on y
trouve des trous là en novembre je veux
vraiment trouvé avec justin trudeau puis
je lui demandais qu'est ce que vous
regrettez de votre mandat d'un contact
de voyage en inde
non seulement pour les costumes pour les
problèmes de sécurité sous le niveau de
l'homme qui s'est infiltré dans la
délégation qui avait déjà été condamné
on n'a pas voulu rencontrer
du côté du gouvernement exige d'être
devant plusieurs jeunes étaient boudés
par le le premier ministe maudit là bas
bref c'est un désastre c'est d'aileurs
et lui le reconnaît d'emblée commencé à
tabac vous savez moi mon mandat bien
étonnant ici lines a été une catastrophe
et on l'a vu dans les sondages
immédiatement dans les semaines qui ont
suivi
d'ailleurs les cours de ce sondage
intéressant parce que après le voyage en
inde la descente des libéraux avec les
plus marquées qu'après la sphère snc
lavalin en terme de points de
pourcentage parce que on revient la
facilité de combat on a tous les
canadiens voyait et c'était
spectaculaire
un ménage peut-être pas à la hauteur de
ce qu'on veut mais c'est ça c'était
visuel c'est facile de digérer la
personne moyenne regard des suns mais
qu'est ce que c'est ça beaucoup plus
facile que des questions légales
complexe et dans un sens c'est ça va
être un référendum sur les quatre années
sur le bilan de monsieur trudeau
choquant quand il va aux autres cette
fois ci alors il doit être en mesure de
défendre son bilan et c'est ce qu'on a
atteint et c'est là où comme joseph va
vous amener rillettes en grande
discussion pour l'instant avec madame
payet mois ci pour moi sont radoucies
stade wattiau combat oui pour moi yacht
collège il est là depuis 10 heures si je
ne me trompe pas alors 25 minutes lancer
dans les longues rencontres et on n'a
pas tardé on a peut-être le temps
d'aller voir philippe vincent foisy qui
vont lui s'envoler avec justin trudeau
après ce point de presse une girafe et
les 20 cents à vancouver oui c'est la
première le premier art est justin
trudeau un rassemblement partisan à
vancouver donc sur une région qui vont
être sûrement disputé avec les verts il
ya des sciages néo-démocrate aussi que
les libéraux espèrent gagner souhaite
ganivelles aussi conserver leurs acquis
à vancouver et comme jose il disait dès
le départ de cette campagne là on va
vouloir faire bonne impression qu on
veut re courtiser les canadiens on a pu
l'effet de nouveauté on ne put l'effet
changement donc on ne purent se voit pu
conclure du pouvoir d'un autre parti
alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire mais on
va dès le départ donné énormément de
promesses donc on va donner toutes les
mesures toutes les nouvelles promesses
électorales dans les premières semaines
de la campagne électorale pour envoyer
le message bien clair qu'on est pas là
juste pour défendre un bilan mais pour
avoir une nouvelle offre pour inciter
les canadiens à se rendre aux urnes le
21 octobre et on va aussi sillonné le
pays donc on sera à vancouver ce soir on
va être à québec d'ici la fin de la
semaine a fait au québec pas à québec
mais au québec d'ici la fin de la
semaine et justin trudeau veut se
promener comme ça beaucoup beaucoup
dès le départ pour vraiment tout
sillonné le pays montrer que rien encore
de qu'on peut rien tenir pour acquis
il va falloir se battre dans toutes les
régions c'est sûr que ce qu'on va voir
ça va être des luttes tête avec les
semaines qui vont se rapprocher la date
de l'élection on va voir des
circonscriptions plus précise on va
aller dans celles où on pense qu'on est
capable de gagner on va aller dans
celles où on espère être capable de les
conserver
donc justin trudeau veut vraiment à
trouver une façon de courtiser les
électeurs mais aussi de leur dire oui à
débouler oui on a fait certaines erreurs
voyage en inde par exemple il
yal'affaire snc-lavalin qui veulent
suivre mais on va être capable de tasser
ça pour parler des nouvelles promesses
des nouvelles mesures qui lb c'est ce
que justin trudeau veut dire veut dire
on a une nouvelle offre là on n'est pas
les libéraux 2015
on est les libéraux de 2019 et quand
vous êtes avec nous vous choisissez
d'avancé c'est le slogan libéral qui est
inscrit sous l'avion sous le nom de
justin trudeau et c'est ce qu'on veut
dire avec nous en avance si vous allez
avec les conservateurs on recule c'est
le message que justin trudeau va vouloir
faire passer
mathématiquement c'est intéressant parce
que on le dit depuis ce matin conservez
tous les sièges en atlantique à des
maritimes c'est à peu près illusoire
donc y aura des pertes là ce qui veut
dire qu'il ya une petite marge de
manoeuvre ils sont à 179 la majorité
c'est 170 ils peuvent en perdent un peu
mais pas beaucoup alors ce qu'on perd en
atlantique
on doit le gagner sur au québec soit en
ontario dans les prairies ont souvent
fait pas beaucoup d'illusions en alberta
encore moins et la colombie britannique
qui sera aussi un terrain important
ouais c'est ça donc le québec va être un
terrain une bataille important parce
qu'on veut faire des gains à cet endroit
là on ne pense être capable d'aller
chercher quelques joints une dizaine
environ
mais là encore tous les partis espèrent
faire des gains au québec donc
mathématiquement ça va être assez
difficile que tous les partis gang 10 ou
15 circonscriptions comme un seul homme
qui roulait donc cesser la bataille du
québec va être bien important de vous le
dit un peu plus tôt la majorité va
peut-être se décider là au québec si les
libéraux les conservateurs sont
majoritaires ou minoritaires l'ontario
la bataille autour de toronto là
vraiment ça va être un enjeu crucial
pour cette campagne électorale et la
colombie britannique
la colombie britannique c'est peut-être
la province qui va tenir
allen le plus tard dans la soirée à
cause parce que les électeurs vont aller
au journal un peu plus tard à cause des
différents fuseaux horaires donc on va
peut-être d'être tenu en haleine
traiteur le 21 octobre au soir qu' on va
attendre les résultats de la
colombie-britannique pour voir justement
il y aura combien de circonscription
pour les libéraux combien de
circonscription pour les conservateurs
est ce que par exemple du hollywood bowl
qui a été au centre de la sphère
snc-lavalin
regardez sa circonscription ça va être
une bataille très serrée elle se
présente comme indépendante
les verts espèrent faire des gains à cet
endroit là et pour le npd
c'est peut-être la province qui va leur
permettre de rester un parti reconnu à
la chambre des communes parce qu'en ce
moment si on regarde les chiffres ça va
pas nécessairement bien pour les néo
démocrates
mais justin trudeau lui veut capitaliser
là tu veux aller chercher ces
circonscriptions la oran où je veux
aller chercher les électeurs et pour
cela il a besoin de leur dire votez pour
moi pour plus que le bilan voté pour moi
pour plus que ce qu'on a fait et oui à
l'environnement oui on a beaucoup parlé
de la châtre ans menteuse mais n'oubliez
pas tout le reste
et voici ce qu'on va faire dans le futur
aussi en matière d'environnement vous
parliez d'être pour les médicaments
d'assurance-médicaments contrôle des
armes à feu ou si on devrait en entendre
parler dans les premières semaines
les libéraux veulent aller de l'avant
avec des mesures plus strictes pour le
contrôle des armes à feu sont vent par
les mesures fiscales aussi on veut
beaucoup beaucoup parlé de classe
moyenne encore une fois comment on va
les aider
comment on veut être capable de répondre
aux préoccupations des canadiens qui
sont inquiets par rapport au coût de la
vie
c'est beau les indicateurs de chômage
c'est beau les indicateurs d'emploi
c'est beau les indicateurs monétaires
aussi plus généraux de pib et autres
mais on sent qu'il ya une crainte quand
même chez les canadiens et ce justin
trudeau veut miser là dessus
très bien merci beaucoup l'avion de
justin trudeau aura peut-être plus de
chance que celui d'un douchez je le
disais plus tôt il fallait à trois
rivières mais ce chiffre doit se poser à
québec monsieur trou d'où s'envolent
enfin couvert donc ça devrait être ça
devrait être plus facile autres coptes
ce que la météo est bonne
là bas mais ça fait partie des imprévus
de campagne que ces déplacements merci
beaucoup on va vous suivre tout au long
de cette campagne alors oui on l'attend
monsieur trudeau d'ailleurs 10h35 et au
dessert maintenant au dessert mais il ya
une question de politesse on veut pas
aller trop vite mais là bon d'espoir
comme si elle est réfléchie c'est madame
payet est ce que oui ou non je le sous
le par c'est pas michael j'adore on se
souvient que quand elle avait reçu
monsieur x avait duré parce que plus que
deux heures quelque chose comme ça mais
lui c'était propres au visage il y avait
une vraie peut on se demander s'il
allait alors général comme dans
l'histoire on vient reposer ça
finalement sassano pas un milieu jack
mais il se dit quoi la somme atteint
faut pas l'enterrer trouvé non il ya des
dynamiques dans les provinces qui font
aussi que y'a pas mort non plus
totalement je veux pas donner
l'impression que c'est terminé il pas
mort mais jack médecine comme jack
médecine et regarde où les autres chefs
vont faire campagne aujourd'hui ils s'en
vont tous dans des circonscriptions
néo-démocrate donc les libéraux sont
avec working juin avec trudeau qui
appartient au niveau des mots quand vous
avez les conservateurs qui sont trois
rivières c'est robert rubin le néo
démocrate qui est là vous avez le bloc
et françois blanchet veut se faire élire
dans bellaing et c'est matthew dubé qui
labellise chambly donc néo-démocrate
russie et les néo-démocrates sont ou
dans leur propre circonscription à
london pour défendre leur
circonscription
vous regardez donc où vont les chefs
aujourd'hui on peut pas dire que du côté
de jacques meeting la campagne par du
bon pied parce qu'il lit clairement pas
le france yves il est temps d'y penser
mais tous les autres veulent manger son
lot chez lui alors là clairement le
quelque chose qui se passe c'est un
patrick sont pas capables d'inverser la
tendance
c'est quelqu'un qui aime les électeurs
qui a une facilité avec les gens qui
peut surprendre parce qu'ils essaient
attentes sont extrêmement basses
actuellement mais c'est clair qui part
avec une campagne électorale où le vent
de face est important il celui qu'il est
celle qu'il a devant lui aussi qui veut
ravir cette troisième place
la voilà madame et qu'on va l'écouter
mais peut-être y perdent en tout cas
écouter ensuite le premier ministre
arrive et il lance sa propre compagnie
et moi je veux le voir pour ce que je
puisse l'entendre et donc ce qui peut
aussi arriver car on sait jamais s'il y
va parler mais par à main a touché ne
veut pas y aller près parce qu'elle a
son propre plein de matches pour cet
après midi écoutez si vous avez des
renseignements rendus furieux et dans un
avion bon d'accord merci c'est la
primeur jack médecine je crois savoir
qu'il n'est pas dans un avion c'est lui
qui va passer donc justin trudeau jack
médecine le bloc québécois
ensuite ils vont venir nous voir c'est
pourquoi ils sont tous là avec leur
caméra c'est pourquoi vous êtes là parce
que au moment où le bloc québécois avec
monsieur blanchet où est donc mais nous
allons nous affoler nous allons être
très enthousiasmé donc ne perdez pas
votre temps à m'applaudir m maintenant
je pense que chacun devrait savoir
[Applaudissements]
je suis à la télé maintenant ah bon
c'est bon savoie voilà voilà je suis là
vous expliquer donc le parti vert reste
dans la réalité
[Applaudissements]
alors bonjour aux et donc nous allons
revenir car nous avons beaucoup de
candidats remarquables et ensuite nous
aurons le lancement bras voilà ce qui se
passe je pense tout simplement qu'il me
fallait vous le dire parce que moi je ne
savais pas trop ce qui se passait
jusqu'à ce que je me branche
donc je vais arrêter par les nous allons
répondre aux questions des médias
donc je suis vraiment dans la gratitude
que vous vous êtes levés ou c'est tout
et j'aimerais vous remercier pour votre
dévouement
donc vous avez dû être présent à l'hôtel
à 6 à 45 ce matin donc nous allons nous
rassembler nous allons entrer en grande
pompe et je vais vous présenter les
candidats et mais je veux voir ce que
les autres vont dire est ce que ça va te
monde donc on se reprend cela veut
également dire que comme nous si vous
êtes comme moi pourquoi je n'ai pas
amené du café ce que vous voulez faire
c'est d'aller chercher un café mais qui
parle très candidement aller oui c'est
ça il n'y avait pas de grand message là
je pense qu'elle ne savait pas qu'elle
est est que qu'elles étaient truffées
pas un oui cherche à la télé en direct
bon ben c'est bien
restons vraie paix c'est ça qui compte
bon y'a une à raccorder les télévisions
et charmante un sens dans le sens que
oui dans des petits faits quel
politicien depuis très longtemps et
donne toujours un peu l'impression du
fandom de partis politiques parfois plus
de préparation s ennuie blanc non mais
en même temps c'est quand même
une chef qui a de grandes ambitions pour
son parti cette fois ci avec toute la
thématique du changement climatique
c'est semble que ces formules ce n'est
maintenant formelle un déclenchement de
campagne
cc oui c'est pas c'est papa était dans
ses salons des cheveux les jo c'est un
projet oui oui alors madeleine vous avez
des nouvelles du premier ministre chef
libéral
on dit que c'est d'acquérir quelques
minutes
on nous a donné deux minutes de préavis
quelques instants où est ce qu'on en dit
rendu il doit rester quelques secondes
maintenant
elizabeth may a indiqué à ses partisans
qui étaient réunis qu elle devait parler
après les autres chefs c'est ce qu'elle
était en scène racontée à ses militants
elle est vraiment pas conformes aux
politiciens traditionnels et si ce qui
peut peut-être l'aider quand on disait
tout à l'heure qu'il ya des électeurs
qui sont peut-être agacé de voir les
policiers se comporter tout le temps de
la même façon elizabeth may a son style
elle n'assume et y en a qui vont l'aimer
il y en a d'autres qui sait à qui ça va
déplaire mais en tout cas elle aura elle
aura essayé de rester intègre à ce
qu'elle est généralement parce que je
voudrais que ce que j'ai vu à la télé il
ya un instant c'est tout à fait le
elizabeth may que je connais depuis
plusieurs années comme quoi cette cette
attention renouvelée au parti vert de
l'europe a changé
les électeurs pourront décider s'ils
aiment ou s'il n'aime pas mais en tout
cas c'était c'était du classique
elisabeth mais je vous dirai très bien
mais déjà que les vrais messages à
l'avenir plus tard quoi oui mais en fait
c'était ça ce parce que son tour devrait
venir plus tard et savaient pas les
laisser devant la télé évidemment oui
c'est une règle numéro 1 que lorsqu'on
est devant un micro il faut dire des
choses avec lesquelles on est à l'aise
mais patrice ont réalisé au sophie
grégoire qui font qu'ils s'approchent du
lutrin monsieur trudeau va s'adresser
aux canadiens pour lancer cette campagne
officiellement donc petit discours et
ensuite il répondra aux questions
d'assumer tout à l'heure que ce film
edward fera partie de cette campagne
virale à temps plein
donc on les avait un peu plus tôt dans
leur vie de famille et voici maintenant
le premier ministre qui remet ses
vêtements de chefs libéral et qui parle
de beagle en campagne j'aimerais qu'on
se rappelle des victimes
il ya 18 ans ni milliers de personnes
ont été assassinées lors de ces
attentats terroristes aux états unis et
l'ue beaucoup de canadiens aujourd'hui
un jour que nous nous préparons à
exercer notre droit démocratique nous
reconnaissons et en auront leur vie
puisse leur mémoire être une bénédiction
pour nous tous et toutes
quelques instants j'ai rencontré son
excellence la gouverneure générale qui a
accédé à ma demande de dissoudre le
parlement
les canadiens se rendront au jour aux
urnes le 21 octobre prochain lors de
chaque élection se trouvait kenesi jeu
nous avons des choix importants à faire
sur l'avenir du pays
on peut décider de cet avenir à bâtir
ensemble en 2015
après une décennie de politique
conservatrice échoué l'économie était à
plat la croissance économique la
création d'emplois la croissance des
salaires
tout est bloqué grâce à un gouvernement
conservateur qui pensaient que
l'austérité et les réductions
budgétaires étaient la réponse à tout
une nouvelle équipe qui était prête à
investir dans les gens et dans leur
communauté
une équipe qui a compris que même si on
vit dans le meilleur pays du monde
il est toujours possible de faire mieux
et bien qu'il nous reste encore
énormément de travail à faire
on a passé les quatre dernières années à
améliorer les choses et on a le bilan
pour le prouver
la pauvreté a chuté le taux de chômage
figurent parmi les plus bas jamais
enregistrés du pays et la création
d'emplois et à la hausse
et tout ça c'est parce que notre équipe
a rejeté les coupes et l'austérité des
années reprend parce qu'à la place on a
décidé d'investir dans la classe moyenne
et dans ceux qui travaillent fort pour
en faire partie
oui foot - money nous avons investi et
nous avons réduit le fardeau fiscal sur
les classes moyennes et augmenter ce
fardeau sur les plus riches est nous
avons arrêté d'envoyer des chèques de
prestations pour enfants aux familles de
millionnaires et nous avons donc mis
plus d'argent entre les mains des
familles qui ont plus de mal à joindre
les deux bouts
nous avons renforcé le régime de
pensions du canada à 4 ans un pays comme
le nôtre les aînés devraient pas avoir
du mal à joindre les deux bouts
nous allons renégocier l'alena ensuite
donc ouvre à un accès commercial à notre
plus grand partenaire commercial à un
moment de protectionnisme américain
accru et d'imprévisibilité au sud de
notre frontière et nous conservons
d'abus davantage notre nature nous
voulons et nous nous assurons que l'eau
soit potable et que l'air soit sain car
nous le devons nous mêmes tout comme à
nos enfants nous voulons nous occuper et
prendre soin de l'environnement
voilà ce qui change vraiment la vie des
gens cet automne les canadiens à nouveau
pourront voter pour le genre de canada
qui veulent connaître dans lequel ils
veulent vivre
nous avons tous un choix fer continue
d'aller de la vincent espère et des
progrès déjà accomplis ou reculer et
retourner aux politiques des années
harper les conservateurs aiment dire
qu'ils sont pour les gens mais ensuite
ils réduisent les impôts pour les riches
et coupe les services pour les autres
la bonne façon de faire c'est pas un
copain qu'on va s'enrichir
c'est pourquoi notre gouvernement a
choisi de faire avancer notre pays
on a choisi des vestiaires dans les
familles dans les travailleurs et dans
nos communautés
on a choisi de faire confiance aux
canadiens au cours des quatre dernières
années plus d'un million de nouveaux
emplois ont été créés on a négocié de
nouveaux accords sur la santé avec les
provinces et des territoires
on a introduit la nouvelle allocation
canadienne pour enfants qui aide les
parents en les donnant des centaines de
dollars libre d'impôt chaque mois on a
sorti neuf cent mille canadiens de la
pauvreté dont trois cent mille enfants
et sous un gouvernement libéral
le canada va continuer d'avancer
attendait au bout du compte la politique
eh bien ça concerne les gens peut-être
vous êtes heures les diplômés qui vient
d'obtenir son diplôme aux néo-canadiens
fait vous avez des enfants vous êtes à
la retraite à l'âge d'or mais qui que
vous soyez vous méritez un vrai plan
pour votre avenir
nous avons beaucoup accompli depuis
quatre ans ensemble
mais la vérité c'est que nous ne faisons
que commencer donc les canadiens ont un
choix important à prendre allons-nous
reculé aux politiques échouent et du
passé où allons-nous continuer d'aller
de l'avant
le choix c'est tout si clark cela et
c'était vraiment à tel point important
moi je veux que nous puissions aller de
l'avant pour chacun et chacune d'entre
nous
bonjour premier ministre qu'est ce que
vous essayez de cash et en refusant de
lever la confidentialité du cabinet pour
que l'agencé puisse faire un tête sur
votre rôle est le rôle de bureaux dans
le scandale de sennecé lavalley réponse
écoutez nous avons été responsables du
plus grand comment dire de la plus
grande renonciation à ce secret dans
l'histoire du canada mais vous êtes le
patron vous êtes dans le point de mire
allez-vous demander à lever la
confidentialité
réponse nous respectons les décisions
prises par nos hauts fonctionnaires et
par le greffier les décisions notre
fonction publique nous respectons la
décision du greffier bonjour toronto
star je suis curieuse vous êtes ici
aujourd'hui les conservateurs ne sont
pas nos ennemis mais nos amis nouveau m
et pourtant votre parti s'attaque est en
train de démoniser les conservateurs que
disait de vous à vos enfants quand vous
parlez d'un douchez réponse
comme je l'aï dit à plusieurs reprises
je ne me permets pas d' attaque
politique mais je vais être très clair
quand il est question de différences
politiques comment engager les canadiens
que la vision de l'avenir les 15èmes
eric cela de voir des contrastes claire
entre une vision qui est ouverte
inclusive et respectueuse des droits
chacun et une perspective qui se dit
pour le peuple mais qui réduit les
services tout comme les impôts pour les
riches que je ne ferais pas d' attaques
personnelles mais je vais être plaît
plaît pointues sur les différents
différence en matière de politiques nos
visions pour le pays sont très
différents entre
l' approche libérale qui est positive et
inclusive et l' approche conservatrice
qui veut prôner les coupures et
l'austérité et pendant cette campagne
victoire électorale on va mettre très au
clair pour les canadiens le choix auquel
ils font face ceux et celles à venir
vous avez dit que vous assumez la
responsabilité mais vous n'étiez pas
d'accord avec les conclusions du rapport
du commissaire laisser kiné vous n'avez
jamais expliqué au gaz et quelles
étaient vos erreurs que pensez-vous
avoir été vos erreurs répond ce matin
comme premier ministre c'est d'être là
de défendre les emplois des canadiens
que ce soit dans les communautés un peu
partout au canada les aînés les
retraités les familles je vais toujours
défendre l'emploi j'étais tout à fait
clair là dessus et je vais continuer de
faire donc aucune erreur vous avez
déclenché les élections et vous demander
aux canadiens de voter pour vous pour
tête pour vous pourriez dire aux 15 1
pourquoi il devrait vous faire confiance
quand nous ne connaissons pas tous les
détails de la sphère snc lavalin malgré
de nombreuses tentatives et en partie il
est question de comités avec une
majorité libérale qui bloquaient le
progrès des enquêtes
réponse nous sommes engagés à faire
croître l'économie pour la classe
moyenne et ceux qui voulaient s'y
joindre c'était au coeur de notre est
promesse électorale intérieure
nous avons livré la marchandise nous
avons vu plus d'un million d'emplois
inscrits en 4 à tous pendant que 900
1000 canadiens ont pu dire au revoir à
la pauvreté
notre engagement à investir dans les
communautés appuyé et offrir 2
réelles chances de succès aux
autochtones grâce entre autres à la
réconciliation en démontrant que la
protection de l'environnement la
croissance économique peuvent aller main
dans la main à chaque étape du processus
et ce n'est pas un ou l'autre voilà les
éléments auxquels on s'est engagé et
c'est exactement ce que nous avons fait
depuis quatre ans déjà
nous sommes les premiers à reconnaître
qu'il reste beaucoup à faire et j'ai
vraiment hâte de parler aux canadiens et
aux canadiennes d'un océan à l'autre
dans les semaines à venir
à propos de nos plans pour continuer de
bâtir un meilleur canada à mesure que
nous avançons tous ensemble question en
ce dix huitième anniversaire des
attentats de new york deux rochers
jeunes se seraient peut-être manqué de
sensibilité de déclencher des élections
lors d'un tel anniversaire tragique
réponses telles que je les dis au début
l'exercice de nos droits démocratiques
fondamentaux
le moment de s'engager sur la réflexion
d'un avenir meilleur pour chacun c'est
une valeur profonde et nous la célébrons
ce sont à la fois des moments où on nous
pensons succès et aux insuccès du passé
ou tragédie
nous pensons aux familles touchées par
ces attentats terrible il y a dix huit
ans et nous allons de l'avant et nous
nous engageons tous les jours une
société plus juste et plus sûr pour
chacun et volage de ceux de quoi il est
question dans cette élection
pensez que c'est une erreur
la question maintenant si vous être
porté au pouvoir est ce que votre
gouvernement
fall à contester judiciairement ou
s'impliquer dans une contestation
judiciaire
effectivement je suis tout à fait en
désaccord avec la loi 21 je ne trouve
pas que dans une société libre on doit
légitimiser ou permettre la
discrimination contre quiconque
je suis très content que des québécois
eux-mêmes soient en train de contester
cette loi en cours soit en train de
défendre la charte canadienne des droits
et libertés
nous suivons de proches tout ce qui ce
fait nous regardons attentivement ces
processus mais pour l'instant ne
trouvons pas que nous trouvons que c'est
contreproductif a pour un gouvernement
fédéral de s'engager directement dans
cette cause humanitaire comme j'ai dit à
plusieurs reprises
je suis profondément contre la loi 21 au
québec je ne crois pas que dans cette
société les brawn devrait permettre ou
légitimer la discrimination quelle que
soit je suis fort content que les
québécois et les québécoises ont choisi
eux même de contester cette loi devant
les tribunaux de défendre la charte des
droits des libertés
j'ai observé cela de très près et j'ai
envisagé des gestes que le chrono en
fédérale pourrait poser mais pour
l'instant je pense qu'il serait contre
productif pour nous de nous engager dans
cette chute du tout quoi qu'il advienne
comme j'ai dit nous surveillons de
proches ce processus est pour l'instant
nous ne trouvons pas que ce serait
productif de s'engager mais nous allons
continuer de suivre attentivement ce
processus et on prendra nos décisions au
cours au cours du processus
hazard comme j'ai déjà dit nous suivons
de très près le processus au québec
pour l'instant nous pensons que ce
serait bien pu productif pour le fédéral
de s'engager dans cette contestation
judiciaire de la loi va tient mais nous
suivons la situation de près et nous
allons évaluer notre position à mesurer
au fur et à mesure du temps
question les millenium sont le bloc le
plus important d'électeurs
comment allez-vous regagner la confiance
des jeunes parce que vous avez promis la
différence mais vous vous êtes montré
tout à fait pareil aux politiciens du
passé
réponse à écouter les millénium ont vu
les changements on a pu sortir beaucoup
de pauvres et et on la crée de la
richesse à mesure que nous avons sombre
et bien on est vraiment le gouvernement
le plus ambitieux quant à la protection
de l'environnement tout bonnement que
notre propre préparant pour la
prospérité accrue des familles un peu
partout au pays
voilà des attentes des jeunes et les
attentes de tous les citoyens face à
leurs gouvernements face à leur pays
face à leur avenir
donc nous allons parler d'une plateforme
très ambitieuse qui visera à une
confiance encore plus grande envers ce
grand et beau pays qui est le nôtre que
vous estimez de contre-productif à
l'idée de vous impliquer dans la
contestation de la loi 21 au québec en
ce moment et vous dites que veulent
continuer de surveiller le dossier au
fur et à mesure qu est-ce que vous
surveillez qu'est ce qui pourrait vous
faire changer d'idée dans des bols on
comprend très bien que dans une société
libre on ne devrait pas être en train de
suspendre des droits fondamentaux on ne
devrait pas est en train de permettre et
de légitimiser la discrimination contre
les citoyens basée sur la religion ou
sur d'autres choses
ah c'est pour ça que nous sommes
préoccupés évidemment par ce projet de
loi mais comme j'ai dit les québécois
eux mêmes sont en train d'amener des
contestations judiciaires sont en train
de défendre à charte des droits et
libertés et en tant que québécois en
tant que gouvernement fédéral
nous surveillons de près ce processus là
et nous regardons comment et si le
gouvernement fédéral a besoin ou devrait
intervenir et c'est
ma décision pour l'instant que je crois
que ce serait contre-productif de
s'immiscer dans le processus légal à ce
moment ci basculement la question c'est
de vous assurer en tant que premier
ministre du canada que cette loi est
contestée jusqu'au bout c'est ce que
j'aime a besoin de comprendre de votre
réponse est ce que c'est son ultime mans
que vous surveillez puis juste battu
vais mettre ma folle web parce que vous
n'avez pas vraiment imposée à ma
première
certains parlent de cette élection comme
étant une élection référendaire sur le
climat il semble y avoir deux clans qui
se dessine d'un côté les conservateurs
de l'autre vous limpide et les verts le
bloc
comment est ce que vous espérez vous
distinguer ce que vous craignez pas que
ce vote classées par pays et qu'ils
profitent aux conservateurs je pense que
les canadiens comprennent très bien que
les changements climatiques représentent
une menace réelle a pas jeu ça notre
planète pas jusqu'à nous communauté mais
bien notre économie aussi et c'est pour
ça que nous avons un plan qui a non
seulement a agi de façon concrète pour
mieux protéger l'environnement que tout
autre gouvernement dans l'histoire de
notre pays mais en même temps qu'ils
préparent nos familles un nouveau jeune
nos travailleurs pour un avenir dans
lequel les nouveaux emplois vont être
lié à une économie plus verte et plus
propre nous avons un plan ambitieux et
pour protéger l'environnement et pour
faire croître l'économie
c'est ce que nous avions démontré au
cours des quatre dernières années
je trouve ça carrément dommage que les
conservateurs ne comprennent encore pas
que les changements climatiques sont une
menace réelle à laquelle il va falloir
s'affronter concrètement encore une fois
on voit les politiciens conservateurs à
travers le pays a dépensé de l'argent du
public pas pour aider dans la
transformation mais à pour contester un
plan qui fonctionne pour les canadiens
nous allons continuer de démontrer par
nos actions et par nos engagements que
les canadiens s'attendent à du
leadership concret
gouvernement convaincu que d'agir contre
les changements climatiques c'est la
seule façon est de protéger les
générations futures et de créer
l'économie de nécessaire pour l'avenir
nous allons suivre attentivement tout ce
qui se passe dans le processus
judiciaire et nous allons prendre nos
décisions au fur et à mesure et si on va
intervenir mais comme j'ai dit je trouve
que ce serait contre-productif
d'intervenir à ce moment ci catherine
avec la presse canadienne toujours sur
le même thème la laïcité vous avez des
moins importants de la vie pour
l'instant je me demandais si cette
décision devait intervenir dans le
processus judiciaire va tenir que vous
soyez minoritaire ou majoritaire
nous allons toujours faire tout ce qui
est nécessaire pour défendre les droits
de tous les canadiens
au québec comme partout au canada les
gens apprécient énormément cette charte
des droits et libertés qui protège nos
libertés fondamentaux et je sais qu'il
ya bien des québécois qui trouve que
dans une société libre on ne devrait pas
légitimiser la discrimination contre
quiconque
qu'est ce que vous répondez aux gens qui
vous accusent de comprendre nos
compromettre vos valeurs de diversité et
d'inclusion
on pourrait presque y les québécois
actuellement j'ai toujours été
extrêmement clair je pense qu'il n'y a
pas un québécois qui ne sait pas que je
suis en désaccord avec ce projet de loi
21 et que ma responsabilité en tant que
premier ministre c'est toujours
d'assurer la défense de des droits de
tous les canadiens
et c'est pour ça que je suis très
content que les québécois eux mêmes sont
en train de contester
seule cette loi devant la cour vous
entamez la campagne à vancouver et c'est
juste à côté d'eux
la circonscription de votre ancien
collègue et maintenant rival joyce au
célèbre reconnaît-il réponse la dernière
fois on s'est rendue à la parade de la
fierté gaie à vancouver et c'est ainsi
que nous avons lancé notre campagne vous
rappellerai qu'il va beaucoup de gens
s'étaient rassemblés ici et dans les
galeries de presse un peu partout la
ville qui ont critiqué que c'était une
grande erreur de ne pas être ici art
avoir pour le lancement de la campagne
électorale libre elle nous avons
démontré que les campagnes se passe sur
le terrain et que le lancement d'une
campagne dans mon deuxième foyer la
colombie-britannique sentait tout à fait
un bond en 2015 et jettera de me rendre
en colombie britannique ce après midi et
j'ai tout à fait apte deux trains peu
partout au pays dans les semaines à
venir il y a beaucoup de qualités
rencontrés sur le choix important qu'ils
ont à faire à savoir est-ce que nous
allons vers l'avenir où nous nous
tournons vers le passé je sais quel
canadien sont stimulés enthousiasmés par
les occasions qui s'offrent à nous et
moi j'ai hâte de me retrousser les
manches et de continuer à travailler
pour eux à tous les jours notre
électorat à vancouver malgré le fait que
plusieurs personnes disaient que c'était
une erreur de ne pas être à ottawa pour
le lancement de la campagne
mais nous avions démontré qu'une
campagne électorale ça se fait à travers
le pays et pas juste à ottawa c'est pour
ça que je suis si content d'aller à
vancouver mais mon deuxième chez moi
pour lancer la campagne
cet après midi et dans les semaines à
venir nous allons nous retrouver partout
au pays pour avoir ces conversations
importantes avec les canadiens sur quels
choix ils vont faire pour les années à
venir
est-ce qu'on va continuer d'avancer
parce qu'on va retourner en arrière vers
les années impaires
vous adversaires vous attaque sur le
plan de l'éthique comment réagissez vous
à l'idée que vous n'êtes pas authentique
à cet égard réponse je pense que les
canadiens les quinzaines savent très
bien que je pollari son attention sur
les choix qui s'imposent sur le canadien
afin que nous puissions aller de l'avant
al'avantage la classe moyenne et ceux
qui veulent se joindre qui va de l'avant
sur la question la réconciliation avec
cet automne et que la seule façon de
bâtir une économie solide c'est de
protéger l'environnement et que les deux
vont de pair
nous sommes un 100% dévoué un meilleur
avenir et c'est pourquoi nous voulons
aller de l'avant merci ces partis
officiellement 40 jours de campagne
justin trudeau qui a fait un discours et
qui a répondu aux questions
justin trudeau qui se pose clairement
comme le leader progressiste versus
l'alternative conservatrice qui veut dit
il
faire revenir les canadiens en arrière
et que lui seul peut continuer la marche
qui l'entreprise
il y a quatre ans maintenant l'économie
s'est améliorée le revenu des gens s'est
améliorée dit il l'environnement est une
vraie bataille les questions vous avez
remarqué mesdames et messieurs ont
beaucoup porté sur la loi 21 au québec
va-t-il comme champion des droits
individuels aider les opposants cette
loi sur la laïcité au québec à aller
devant les tribunaux va-t-il participer
activement la bataille devant les
tribunaux
la réponse pour l'instant dit-il
essayant de retenir ce pour l'instant le
gouvernement fédéral ne sera pas un
partenaire actif ne va pas participer
activement dans les luttes donc devant
les tribunaux tour de table avant
d'aller retrouver nos ex que je vais
vous présenter pour le long de la
campagne
mais tour de table et que je commence
avec vous mais ce qui est clair c'est
que le il se campe comme étant le seul
progressiste qui a défendu remporté en
faisant référence à a thing as
et au bloc bien sûr et il se pose comme
étant le seul rempart contre un danger
de retourner en arrière
la dernière fois le triple pilier sur
lequel s'était puis juste un être doux
pour l'emporter c'est le vote
progressiste
c'était coalisés autour de lui le vote
des jeunes et le vote des femmes alors
il ya besoin encore de ces trois piliers
pour espérer l'emporter c'était eux qui
parlent aujourd'hui dans ses discours là
parce qu'il parle d'avancés de peau
retournée aux années impaires de palier
dans l'austérité au contraire d'aider la
classe moyenne donc il essaie de
reconstituer la coalition qui lui a
permis de l'emporter à l'époque mais
maintenant il y le gouvernement sortant
est clairement un premier point de
presse un peu plus compliqué que ce que
ça avait été la dernière fois lors ce
qui était troisième dans les intentions
de vote souvenez-vous beaucoup decency
lavalin le projet de loi 21 qui
maintenant loi il là qu'il appelle
encore le projet de loi 21 mai c'est une
loi au québec maintenant sur la laïcité
il ya un bilan défendre mieux des plus
grandes responsabilités puis c'est clair
que la manière dont ils vont être
capables de se défendre sur ces sujets
là vaut aussi teinté la campagne
électorale les stratèges vous vous
répétez souvent qu'une campagne
électorale ça a beau être scénarisé la
minute près c'est la manière dont on
réagit aux imprévus ou question un peu
piège des journalistes à ce qui peut
surgir dans l'actualité qui fait en
sorte que oui ou non on a une bonne
campagne et très bien josé vos
impressions générales
oui mais c'est ça confirme exactement ce
que je disais au début c'est vraiment il
prend le camp progressiste et 10 et donc
il parle aux néo-démocrates par l'ovaire
et d'y goûter
moi je pouvoir je suis celui qui a le
plus de chance de rester au pouvoir donc
c'est bon on voulait cette vision là si
vous voulez qu'on continue ensemble
voilà sur la question est est ce que je
suis j'ai noté aussi c'est que sa
première référence dans son discours
était à l'économie alors ça c'est il
parle directement à indochine quand il
fait ça et il dit bon nous nous
investissons à les canadiens donc
difficile bravo et aussi l'austérité et
les compressions c'est ce qu'on va
entendre vraiment
pour ça les gens t il le dit avec et sur
manoire était un
je les trouvais très habile parce que il
parle mais il doit parler en même temps
au canada régler et au québec et dire la
même chose ça doit être cohérent et
conseiller conseiller il y aurait je
pense qu'il a réussi à le faire quand il
dit pour l'instant il parle au canada
il leur laisse l'espoir que s'il est
réélu il va suivre le processus au point
de s'en mêler
4 cet espoir aux québécois il ya une
phrase clé at il dit il n'y a pas un
québécois qui ne sait pas que je suis
opposé à la loi 21
donc c'est connu ma position est connue
et puis s'il avait voulu badiner mais
ils pouvaient pas évidemment il aurait
posté je suis quand même au sommet des
sondages malgré tout donc cesser connu
csu et pour lui donc ce sera pas un
handicap parce qu'ils étaient très
claires sont très actifs au cours des
prochains mois des projets mais il a
laissé l'espoir aux canadiens geeks sont
pour une fois pour les prochaines
l'impression qu'on est pas pour les
prochains jours contre x et contre
productif parce qu'ils perdraient des
votes musique ses opposants aussi vont
pas toucher à ça alors il est sur ma
place est sur moi ce qui m'a frappé
c'est que ses adversaires ne sont pas un
médecin est aussi dans l'autre il a fait
allusion dans son discours
spécifiquement il a dit les
conservateurs aiment dire qu'ils sont
fous rires de pipeau c'était le slogan
de notre foire pendant la dernière
élection en ontario il sait de quoi il
parle et après ça il faut des coupures
c'est là c'est ce qu'on vit en ontario
il a dit aux producteurs bureautique
c'est un code pour donald trump et dis
ça parce qu'il sait que les gens ne
veulent pas quelqu'un qui peut pas
prédire qu'il est dans l'autre up
quelqu'un qui dit une chose puis
d'autres choses le land est le plus
important site et là il fait énorme
révisions historiques parce qu'il
revient d'ici bas coûts d austérité que
l'économie marchait pas tu es la chute
du prix de pétrole en 2015 qui a causé
des problèmes pour stephen harper aurait
causé des problèmes pour n'importe et
mes voiles utilisées
c'est complètement faux ce qu'il dit
mais en tout cas ils cette révision
historique pour son profit et il dit pas
un dieu parce que c'est pas demain du
chiffre déjà en perd ses deux alors
c'est la direction c'est très économique
ce qui fait mais c'est très spécifique à
ces acteurs très bien madeleine un petit
mot que j'étais sur place
beaucoup de questions sur snc lavalin
aussi est ce que vous leur avez vous
comme y soyez plus précis
est ce que vous allez libérer le secret
des ministres pour qu'ils puissent
collaborer davantage avec la grc et
c'est donc on sent là que ça cette
motion ne s'ennuiera pas non plus par
magie
j'imagine que ce n'était pas idéal pour
lui cette une du globe and mail
aujourd'hui quand on parle de début de
campagne qu'on doit réussir et signe
c'est sûr qu'il a un défendre un bilan à
défendre mais en même temps c'est un
caillou dans son sud on va écouter le
leader du npd et on revit et jörg aux
attaques et chuck the world
j'aimerais reconnaître ceux qui ont
perdu leur vie lors des attentats de 18
ans et les premiers répondants qui ont
fait preuve d'autant de courage nos amis
nous sommes d'ici à lundi
elle est tellement belle j'ai passé cinq
ans ici quand je me suis rendu air à
l'université weston j'ai des souvenirs
vraiment fort et du style
j'ai pu m'occuper de mon frère nous
avons eu de la misère
j'ai dû travailler juste pour joindre
les deux bouts et la famille à aider
et avec le soutien la nourriture et ça
m'a rappelé d'une valeur for canadian
j'aurais pas pu traverser cela sans leur
succès est ici ce à croix où les
canadiens croire on y croit nous prenons
soin les uns des autres c'est ça cette
valeur canadienne profonde à laquelle je
crois et que j'ai incarné vous savez
tous que j'adore le canada et je pense
que nous pouvons le rendre meilleur
plus tôt aujourd'hui j'ai eu la chance
de parler avec des séquences et jack
jessica hill enceinte et elle a survécu
au cancer
elle m'a parlé de la difficulté et à
quel point il est difficile de se payer
les médicaments sans remboursement des
médicaments par une séance c'est quelque
chose qu'il écrase jeux racontait maxime
jack qui sont tous les deux la retraite
helmond parle lui de leurs
préoccupations de leurs inquiétudes sur
lui dépenses qu'ils paient eux-mêmes ils
ne savent pas à quoi s'attendre
ils ne savent pas comment ça va leur
coûter pour les soins dentaires ou des
nouvelles lunettes
j'estime que nous pouvons eu lieu nous
occuper de gens comme just can't see
jack mais nous le pouvons le faire que
si nous trouvons le courage de nous
attaquer ou aux intérêts puissants en
haut de la pyramide
nous pouvons élargir la couverture pour
qu'on puisse payer les médicaments pour
tous est même allé au-delà de cela pour
les soins des daims la santé mentale et
les soins des yeux
[Applaudissements]
wick indio da nous pouvons le réussir
lui uniquement si nous avons le courage
de résister aux lobbyistes et ou
stratège de coller ces grandes sociétés
nous pouvons construire 500 mille
nouvelles résidences abordable et nous
attaquer à la crise du logement
nous pouvons le faire mais seulement si
nous avons le courage de nous en prendre
aux blanchisseurs de capitaux
spéculateurs qui influencent tellement
les prix et nous pouvons également vous
aider les canadiens qui font face à
certains des prix les plus élevés du
monde pour des téléphones cellulaires
internet uniquement si nous avons le
courage de nous attaquer aux grandes
compagnies de télécoms nous pouvons agir
maintenant aider avec le climat est créé
300 mille nouveaux emplois de qualité
mais seulement si nous avons le courage
de nous attaquer aux grands pollueurs et
de mettre fin aux subventions aux
carburants fossiles
nous vivons dans un pays où les riches
sont de plus en plus riches
un pays où la majorité de la population
n'a pas accès aux mêmes avantages
un pays où le gouvernement conservateurs
et libéraux ont créé un système qui
profite aux riches et qui laisse tomber
la reste entre nous furieuse comme il ya
quatre ans justin trudeau trudeau nous a
charmés avec des belles paroles et des
promesses vides
il disait ce qu'il fallait dire mais n'a
rien fait par la suite derrière des
portes closes justin trudeau fait tout
ce que les grandes sociétés lui impose
c'est tout à fait clair que justin est
rude ou n'est pas qu'ils être est elle
ou chez les conservateurs ne sont pas
non plus la réponse ils vont réduire les
impôts pour les plus riches
elles vont réduire les services dont
vous et vos familles ont besoin
vous allez payer le prix avec les des
soins ne sentais encore plus cher et les
médicaments encore plus cher est une
crise du climat qui s'aggrave nous font
une série des promesses mais trop
souvent ils ne tiennent pas parole quand
vient le temps de choisir entre les
intérêts de la population ou ceux des
grandes multinationales
leur choix est clair ils choisissent
ceux des pétrolières et des compagnies
pharmaceutiques
quand on veut des résultats différents
il faut faire des choix différents dans
cette élection se résume un choix clair
sookie pouvez vous compter pour se
battre pour vous sauver soleil alors
donc cette élection si un choix très
clair qui va se battre pour vous sur qui
pouvait vous comptez quand j'étais jeune
je ne me suis jamais imaginé que
quelqu'un qui avait mon apparence
pouvait se présenter au poste de premier
ministre
combien de temps les gens m'ont dit ce
que je ne pouvais pas faire et
maintenant les enfants viennent me voir
et me disent en te voyant j'ai
l'impression que je pourrais faire
n'importe quoi
ça c'est vraiment inspirant
oui avec nous avons beaucoup de
possibilités à vivre dans les 40
prochaines journées
nous allons présenter un message
d'espoir aux gains dès que nous pour
bâtir le pays de nos rêves où chacun
peut se sentir chez soi les besoins
santé quand on a besoin et de l'eau
potable de l'air pur à respirer de bons
emplois un bon avenir radieux
vous avez partout je me rends je
rencontre des gens qui travaillent fort
qu'ils veulent est traité avec équité et
qui veulent vraiment bâtir une bonne vie
pour eux mêmes et leurs familles voilà
les gens vivre lesquels les partis néo
démocrate s'est toujours battu si ces
gens là pour qui je suis là devant vous
merci sa campagne voulant dire à ses
militants c'est pas nous ne sommes pas
morts nous allons lutter jusqu'au bout
est revenu au oui avec questions du
journaliste me veulent
on va l'écouter ce simili sondages sont
plus faibles que au moment où thomas
mulcair a quitté le parti
donc on dit que vous allez avoir du mal
même à retenir les ch que vous avez
maintenant à la chambre des communes
réponse écoutez moi ce que j'entends des
gens c'est que i les en ont marre des
gouvernements qui rendent la chose plus
facile pour les riches et plus de ses
brevets ils veulent quelqu'un qui va
défendre l'intérêt de monsieur et madame
tout le monde qui va élargir la
couverture des soins de santé
je pense au fait par exemple que nous
sommes mis dans cette position parce que
les gouvernements ont décidé de rendre
la vie plus facile pour les grandes
pharmaceutiques
je suis confiant que les gens vont nous
des champions
de l'avis de chacun et qu'on travaille
fort pour eux sur l'abordabilité london
en ontario à jordan amex leurs contrats
avec les véhicules blindés légers qu'ils
doivent être vendues à l'arabie saoudite
mais que vous voulez annulé que dites
vous à ses travailleurs à ces
travailleuses réponse leur dit que le
canada a beaucoup de besoins d'un nous
forces canadiennes que nous pouvons
certainement assainies des contrats pour
notre propre approvisionnement et que
ces personnes qui est un vrai fort
devrait continuer d'avoir ces contrats
ou certainement un vendredi des
équipements à des pays qui ne sont pas
répressif syli à un moment où il
faudrait annuler un contrat militaire
c'est un pays qu on allègue est
responsable de l'assassinât d'un
journaliste qui est succombé de gens au
yémen et qui en fait réprime les droits
de la personne de leurs propres citoyens
donc nous pouvons avoir certainement ces
emplois protégés par des contrats
militaires ailleurs que dans les pays
aux régimes aussi répressif que l'arabie
saoudite
j'excuse c'était pendant
l'applaudissement g j'aime pas je manque
la question christian noël de
radio-canada mongeau et bonjour la grc
semble avoir de la difficulté à
interroger les gens dans l'histoire de
sennecé lavalin et les allégations
d'obstruction à la justice
si c'était possible d'interviewer ces
gens là est ce que vous pensez qu'on
apprendrait vraiment quelque chose de
neuf
oui bien sûr parce que ce qu'on a
entendu des ministres ils ont dit qu'ils
ont des choses à partager mais à cause
d'eux le fait qu'ils aient non ils n'ont
pas le droit de partager leurs histoires
et non et non plus où la chance de
partager cette histoire avec la
commissaire à l'éthique
donc ce qu'on a eu les reportages de
commencer à douter qu'elle a dit qu'
elle était approché par des ministres
ils ont vu lui partager leur histoire
mais il ne pouvait pas à cause
le fait qu'ils n'ont pas le droit de le
faire vous voulez vous faire le champion
de monsieur madame tout le monde
les conservateurs les libéraux veulent
aussi aider la classe moyenne tout le
monde veut le faire les conservateurs
les libéraux semblent avoir une campagne
complètement nationale de votre côté les
moyens sont moins grandes villes
campagnes peut-être un peu plus
régionaliser pourquoi ce que les gens
devraient voter pour vous si vous avez
moins de chance de former le
gouvernement maintenant on a une
quinzaine qui va être nationale on va
voyager à travers les pays mais en fait
la question c'est ça oui les convives
d'hab on dit qu'il est laid l'ap
monsieur madame tout le monde
mais c'est quoi le bilan est toujours
couplé services dont les gens ont besoin
est toujours couplé services comme les
soeurs ils se sentent et l'éducation
on peut voir la preuve ici
à l'intérieur ils ont coupé tous les
services que les gens ont besoin dont
les gens ont besoin
donc c'est clair ce qu'ils font est
aussi si on regarde le bilan c'est
toujours le cas contre la priorité de la
population et l'écran compagnie les
conservateurs et les libéraux toujours
choisi les priorités de l'écran
compagnie sas et les gangs à sion dans
cette élection c'est qui qui vous pouvez
se battre pour vous et en fait je dis
que c'est les [ __ ] qui ont toujours
montré cette volonté de travail pour
monsieur madame tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais vous poser la question qui
sont suivies les questions de problème
la campagne devez-vous faire afin de
tourner la page sur les obstacles les
entraves dont on a parlé face à votre
campagne
réponse écoutez nous voulons changer
comment la politique se joue au canada
depuis quelques années nous avons vu
cette feuille de route que les
gouvernementaux voix n'ont pas vraiment
réagi aux besoins des gens je vais vous
offrir un exemple concret regardez le
coût des médicaments
c'est quelque chose qui préoccupe les 15
etc alourdi leurs vies regardez les
engagements de monsieur trudeau il a
promis de réduire le coût des
médicaments par un petit changement qui
aurait établi une liste de pays pour
l'esprit comparatif il abandonne islah
et pourquoi c'est caen 4 1 la rencontre
et les lobbys plus de 875 fois donc les
lobbies des grandes sociétés et par
conséquent il a abandonné son engagement
c'est un choix ce n'est pas une croatie
dans ce que nous faisons canadiens et
aux canadiennes c'est que nous nous
engageons à nous battre contre les
grandes puissances commerciales et de
nous battre pour monsieur madame tout le
monde
question mais vous avez des obstacles
personnels à surmonter
je pense écoutez c'est vrai
qu'historiquement j'ai surmonté des
obstacles et c'est la même chose
aujourd'hui mais cela ressemble à la vie
de tout un chacun les femmes par exemple
ont du mal à avancer leur carrière et
qui sont sous représentées dans la
plupart des acteurs regardent et surtout
que ce soit dans la culture corporative
ou dans l'inversé les femmes sont sous
représentées
les gens font face à des barrières selon
leur orientation sexuelle
l'or
langue parlée ce sont des défis
quotidiens pour beaucoup de canadiens
alors moi je comprends ces gens là
j'espère que les gens pourront voir en
moi quelqu'un qui comprend ces réalités
et qui veut bâtir un pays où il n'y a
pas d'obstacles où les gens n'ont pas à
faire face à ces entraves fondée sur
leur identité ils peuvent être célébrée
pour qu'ils sont et ils peuvent vraiment
offrir le meilleur d'eux mêmes et ceux
réalisés entièrement dans ce beau canada
[Applaudissements]
jacques médecine qui donc dit oui j'ai
été habitué à l'adversité il en aura
besoin
jour 1 de cette campagne électorale les
le npd à 39 circonscriptions à protéger
et l'on parle pas de game nécessairement
bien sûr que lui voudrait en faire mais
alex nous disait si justement au début
quand on regarde les cinéraire du chef
pour les débuts de campagne
il va protéger ses acquis et où hélas
quelle est la province où il ya plus de
députés ça reste au québec avec 14
actuellement donc la tâche un petit mot
rapide est énorme pour monsieur singh
qui en est à sa première campagne il
faut le souligner son caucus du québec
est le plus important mais moi j'ai
trouvé qu'il manque un peu de france est
ce qu'on l'a beaucoup de france j'ai
fait le calcul il ya eu 8 phrase sur les
53 que prononcé qui est en français
c'est 15% de son discours quand tu veux
parler des québécois c'est peut-être pas
suffisant donc je pense qu'il va y avoir
un ajustement à faire du côté de jacques
médecin que c'est pas parce que tu es à
london en ontario que pour les québécois
qui t'écoutent ce soit une grande
campagne pancanadienne faut s'ajuster à
chaque fois sinon c'est un discours
assez classique du npd l'on parle à la
base des travailleurs j'ai trouvé que ça
prenait quand même du courage pour dire
qu'on allait éventuellement annuler le
contrat avec l'arabie saoudite sur les
chars d'assaut qu'on va envoyer là-bas
parce que si les talents d'une c'est là
où les héros bella emplois sont créés ça
prenait un certain courage pour le reste
je portais très surpris pendant logement
social assurant une expérience les frais
aussi ça ça peut peut-être parler aux
électeurs ou book contribuables les
frais de cellulaires beaucoup trop élevé
laissant son style traditionnel jumping
contre les lobs et lui dit moi je ne
suis je ne serai pas gêné de me battre
contre des grandes corporations mais
entre temps il ya une bataille très
clair à faire sur le terrain qui est
loin loin d'être gagné je vous présente
mesdames et messieurs ceux qui sont avec
nous à chaque semaine et jusqu'à la
soirée électorale yolande james
nos ex juin les api de nos sexes
[Rires]
françoise boivin tahoua michael fortier
à québec gilles duceppe à montréal
bonjour à vous quatre piscines
alors c'est parti d'abord premier tour
de table rapide qu'est ce que vous allez
vous surveiller particulièrement dans
cette campagne qui commence violente je
commence avec vous mais c'est sûr qu'on
va suivre la campagne du côté du premier
ministre de voir ce matin quand même
dans sa déclaration d'ouverture patrick
a été capable de bien cadrer ce qu'on
appelle son bal des costumes ce qu'ils
souhaitent être le récit entre lui et le
parti conservateur
du côté des conservateurs faudra voir
comment monsieur scheer voss s'imposer
se définir dans la campagne ce matin je
le voyais avec l'avion le chum le nom
scherrer était quand même en majuscules
ça démontre à quel point il ya quand
même donné beaucoup de place à mr ford
et l'équipe de la résistance il faudra
voir comment il va s'imposer durant la
campagne et monsieur signe évidemment
qu'on vient de voir
c'est très difficile pour lui malgré le
fait et les collègues l'ont noté qui a
pas suffisamment parlé en français pour
dire que ce que des générations québec
qui a le plus de députés des députés
mais je pense que c'est important pour
lui de sortir sans paniquer parce que
quand on aura partage après reportages
viendront rappeler à quel point qui
s'abat pas bien tu veux quand même
assuré d'avoir été candidat prêt à faire
campagne mais effectivement il ya des
ajustements à faire au niveau du
français s'il veut séduire le vote
québécois on va coûter le chef du bloc
convient tout de suite avec vous 4
rester là merci on écoute il françois
blanchet qui lance à son tour sa
campagne
on est calme et ne veut pas d'un mot
alors il ya des ajustements il y avait
justement début de campagne
manifestement il attendre le coup alors
il va parler
il va parler et quand il parle on
l'écoutera mais ne veux pas le regarder
à on rappelle que les françois blanchet
qui lui ad mis la barre haute
il veut doubler la députation au québec
passé de 10 à 20 et julie mme marchot de
journalisme zepter que même on parle de
30 la alors la barre est très très hot
le travail va être difficile il y aura
des grosses batailles dans le québec
francophone en cette élection qui
commence je pense qu'il a l'air est trop
près
mais quand ils feront les roms permettez
moi d'abord d'avoir une pensée pour nos
voisins américains en cette date du 11
septembre qui rappelle de bien tristes
souvenirs
cependant ici au québec
soyez certains que nous avions
terriblement hâte mais vous n'imaginez
pas le plaisir que nous aurons nous les
soixante et dix huit candidates et
candidats du bloc québécois au cours des
six prochaines semaines nous allons avec
le coeur la passion et la dignité qui
font de nous des québécois vous
présenter une offre politique et nous
avons choisi de le faire à québec parce
que québec ou de commencer à québec
parce que québec
c'est notre seule capitale nationale
c'est à québec qui lie à notre seul
parlement national avec un gouvernement
qui pour la première fois depuis
longtemps de façon majoritaire affirme
affiche un nationalisme décomplexée
qu'il faut dire qui fait du bien une
élection c'est choisir qui va porter
notre voix qui va être fidèles à ce que
nous sommes à ce que vous n'êtes pas
comme province mais bel et bien comme
nation des gens sains qui vous allez que
vous reconnaitre des gens qui sont comme
vous autres des gens qui le sont pour
vous autres qui va parler pour le québec
qui va préserver et promouvoir les
intérêts du québec qui va offrir un
projet au québec pour le québec
savait il ne s'agit pas tant de formuler
des attaques
nous devons faire une offre politique en
revanche il ya quand même quand même des
constats fin
parce que pour que les québécois se
reconnaissent dans leurs élus il faut
que ces élus partagent les mêmes valeurs
une valeur d'identification profonde à
la langue française
la valeur d'égalité entre les sexes la
valeur importante est étonnamment revenu